foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey okay everybody holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're having some kind of problem you
have no idea all of the issues that
we're having like before this [ __ ]
show started holy crap yeah the uh
the routers failed for some reason
getting red lights on them it didn't
have anything to do with us that was the
service and we haven't had that happen
for it for like forever and it happened
well it started happening like 15
minutes ago yeah it was kind it happened
a couple times because I was trying to
like upload some files like at the last
minute like some graphic design [ __ ]
that I just did that needed to get done
and I was kind of admit it kept
disconnecting and I'm just like what the
[ __ ] and then it seems to have resolved
itself whatever it was it wasn't us it
was the service and then um Jenny was
freaking out and everything and I got
[ __ ] mad and the damn pitcher flew
off the wall
yeah I have a big you can't see it
obviously but I had a big uh Daria
Argento profondo Rosso like poster
that's framed like right up there in
there for [ __ ] and it's been it's not
well not yet since we've moved in here
and put it up when I moved in and it
fell down and it pulled down yeah it
pulled the the
screw out of the wall
and it pulled down it so happened that
the frame on that had like my white
thing that we're using for the light for
the soft bounce on the light yeah so
then we had to like [ __ ] around with
that and like figure out we didn't have
time to put the ship back up on the wall
but yeah we put the white thing back up
we have some weird [ __ ] but Jesus Christ
I mean this just like on top of
because I was telling Tom before I was
like I've been really excited about
doing this show because I love Pirates
and you know all about like Florida
history and stuff and I wanted to do
like I did a lot of research for it but
I wanted to do more I felt like I didn't
do enough because I just haven't had
time I mean yeah the last two or three
days I've gotten
piled on like with graphic design stuff
which doesn't usually happen it's like
usually like spaced out but there'll be
like some time periods when somebody's
like hey can you do a poster and I'm
just like yeah sure and then like seven
more people are like hey can you know
poster I need it today hey can you logo
I need that today hey can you do you
know and so I have like this big [ __ ]
list of stuff and I was just kind of
like really I think customers have to
come first I know that but it's just
kind of like she's getting upset about
it and I'm like Jenny but it's gonna be
all right I always got to settle her
down she because she always has more
material than we absolutely need and
here's the thing there's so much so many
cool pirate cases all right that we
could do 10 20 shows they probably have
whole channels well that's why I'm just
dedicated to like Florida mainly like I
said I'm just I'm just covering like
sort of the main Florida pirates look at
what she has it's probably four or five
hours worth of material so it it's not
as much as it looks like as much as it
looks like no I know that but I'm just
saying I don't I I kind of wish that I'd
had like more time actually the reason
why it's so long is because I didn't
have enough time to go in there and like
edit out like stuff that I didn't need
like I did do that a little bit but so
yeah so this is florida-centric piracy
and uh looks like people are starting to
come in there
yes and how I'm feeling everybody's
asked me how I feel
um today was like the first day where I
felt pretty decent I'm still not 100 I
can still feel a little bit up in here
like I feel like I need to blow my nose
a little bit I might have to go get my
[ __ ] snot rack but yeah I know it's
terrible it's so gross but we'll see
uh I Dro went out and got some rum
it's a Bacardi yeah so we have rum today
yeah for the pirate Beach you should
have got Captain Morgan uh they had it
but the um it was spiced rum and I don't
think that would mix too well with the
fruity fruit juice that we have Fruity
Fruity fruit juice okay what kind of
fruit juice is that I can't really do
all I can taste is rum in that that is
um a tropical punch
okay mine's passion fruit I don't like
passion fruit not really for some reason
so I don't hate it it's just not my
favorite you know what I'm saying the uh
Bacardi
Puerto Ricans Bacardi rum it's the clear
stuff is uh more versatile you can mix
it with the uh rum is in many ways like
a vodka it's it's you know
is similar
yeah you can mix it with lots of stuff
you know what I mean yeah we start
dealing with spice rum though you
you can only do that but you can you
really kind of I think you're really
supposed to drink that [ __ ] just
straight well the good [ __ ] probably
I don't know what you want to rock I
don't really know I'm not a bartender so
I don't know what you do with the spice
stuff and we just I I make basic [ __ ]
cocktails yeah I don't like worry too
much about it for you people who don't
have access to Rum
rum is [ __ ] awesome
rum is so awesome they used to make
cakes bait uh based in rum when I was a
little kid there's a lot of rum candies
in the 70s and rum cake remember that
well just to get some cupcakes they had
rum just a few years ago uh where I used
to work when we had Christmas parties
and somebody would always bring rum
balls yeah and man if you ate enough of
those
you'd be uh stumbling around a little
bit they were very strong they were
really good though for some reason rum
kind of started to go a little bit out
of style but they I guess rum was a food
group back when we were kids it was like
a food group and back in Pirate days
back in Pirate days well rum is good in
in desserts and stuff it mixes well with
like sweet things yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't Baked Alaska have rum in it
well I've made baked Alaska before but
it was so long ago that I don't remember
if it had rum in it or not
yeah Mr 88 said isn't rum the official
drink of pirates everywhere yeah that's
why we got some well that grog
which whatever the [ __ ] that is whatever
that was
I think Grog might have been kind of
like a beer
you guys can check on it or toilet water
yeah they just drank whatever yeah later
there's all kinds of there's all kinds
of dab
oh
Tales you know I mean that they would
mix
seawater and rum and drink it I doubt
that though
that seems like not not a great idea you
know
Camp I said rum is good in mint drinks
oh yeah I guess so I guess it would be
yeah
um that's the thing it's [ __ ] time
Pirates
yeah I've been reading a book I didn't
finish it this is what I wanted to
finish this book it's not necessarily
the book that I'm reading it's not about
Florida Pirates specifically but it's
called I bought it when I was in St
Augustine and I haven't read it yet
but it's called under the Black Flag and
it's actually more about
why we have like the um sort of popular
romantic notion of pirates and like
versus the reality like what real
pirates were like versus like what movie
Pirates are like yeah
um and and on and where like all of the
kind of tropes that we have about
Pirates came from yeah the Disney
Pirates absolutely that was that's not
how it was
I mean some of this stuff I mean I mean
I haven't got that far into the book
some of the stuff like the way they
dressed and stuff like that was kind of
similar yeah um and somebody asked about
uh parrots and they said you know it
seems crazy but parrots were kind of
like a big thing
you know in trade because they were
pretty and they could talk and
everything like that and they were from
like you know South America and
everything so a lot of people would pay
like for pirates and stuff you bring
them so they said it's not crazy to
think that like some Pirates did
probably there was I think there was one
that had a parrot remember because
there's there's a lot here here's
something else well a lot of it comes
from Treasure Island from Long John
Silver which was not who's not a real
guy no but uh they they did know the
source material
uh and uh their pirates that were known
for doing crazy [ __ ]
um
they were also kind of pimp-like
evidently they [ __ ] loved
to dress up in finery when they were
some of them did yeah when they would
come come ashore they weren't like that
maybe at Sea because you know it's it's
a miserable impractical but when they
would come ashore they would just
[ __ ] wear the most outlandish [ __ ]
um I guess before we get into this it
looks like people are starting to show
up
go ahead and dispel a common
misunderstanding of pirates pirates were
not criminals
Pirates were the enemies of mankind but
they weren't criminals they were
closer to mercenaries of the sea you had
to have a license to be a pirate a
pirate well no you had to have a license
to be a privateer Privateer which was
like the same thing basically it is but
other Pirates other Pirates did not have
any licenses they just did what the [ __ ]
ever yeah that's what I'm saying well
that's the distinction if you're a
privateer you were a pirate in all but
you had the sanction of like your
government or your crown or whatever
yeah they were kind of just
most of them had a had a license by
either the Spanish Empire the French or
the or or the British to raid only the
the uh the vessels of a like an opposing
Nation
then they were able to do it now some of
them did just kind of do whatever the
hell they wanted to do but they were
hunted down and killed well not we're
all being hunted down and killed anyway
uh if you were raiding [ __ ] the
Spanish the Spanish were after you even
though you had that license
and they treated they would hang you
like a common Criminal
um now they were sometimes depending on
where you were caught if it was kind of
a more neutral area like you know Haiti
or [ __ ] Puerto Rico a governor there
might give you leniency but it all
depended on what what nation you're
working with and the money power is
behind it but I'm sure Jenny has a lot
more details about it uh but
they were kind of like mercenaries more
than else
they were vicious though some of them
yeah uh and I kind of feel like the
earlier Pirates they almost like not all
of them obviously but a lot of them kind
of had more of like a code of honor
where it's kind of like hey they take
over your ship they would go hey uh you
want to join our crew recruit if you
don't we're gonna like cut you up and
throw you in the ocean yeah but so but a
lot of people joined voluntarily like
because sometimes you had to think some
of the Pirates were like escaped slaves
or you know indentured servants things
like that who were looking for a better
life and were like hey piracy that
sounds like pretty fun at certain times
there were also in League with Miss
Sonic lodges and temples too uh and they
were supporters of democracy which was a
bad word back in those days pirate Crews
were democratic they largely were
unusually but um yeah unlike a lot of
the more official uh navies and things
yeah the Imperials weren't like that
everything was about uh what Birthright
you were and it was socio-net economic
standing and whatever the whatever the
crown said that's that's who was in
charge not pirate Cruise pirate Crews
tended to elect their captains and elect
certain people to positions and uh they
were all equal they shared the booty
whatever they stole they sure I mean the
captain and the officers got more but
like everybody got got it you got your
payment according to what your job was
yeah and uh skilled labor you know the
the most some of the highest paid on the
crew would have been Navigators most
people were not real good Navigators you
had to be literate you had to learn how
to use Sextant and you had to knew how
to charts and everything and you had to
learn how to make maps as you go because
they didn't Maps weren't completed and
not no two map was the same really
um but uh the Navigator was the [ __ ]
that and a captain they made the most
money now they were weird too you know
what I mean like they'd
Edward Teach
when he got mad at his wife he said we
got to share the booty he shared his
wife with the rest of the crew they did
all kinds of weird [ __ ]
yeah they uh they had no problem with
rape murder torture none of that
um yeah I kind of feel like a little bit
there's been kind of like a romanticized
version of them yeah now these dudes are
bad uh yeah they they were yeah they
were they were I would say on par with
something like a Central American Narco
army or cartels they were like that
I mean they basically just wanted
plunder and if you were in their way
they give a lot of times they would give
you the option hey you want to join our
crew yeah if you said no then they would
probably just kill you I think
testosterone and Adventure had a lot to
do with it too uh and yeah they liked to
brag and to be seen as heroic and brave
and they did crazy [ __ ] in combat
um
they were not trying to sink enemy ships
they were trying to capture them yeah
they wanted the ships they wanted they
wanted the ship and they wanted to steal
the ship there was a bunch of stuff that
that they wanted and and they had all
the tactics to get this done and one of
the main things was horror they were
horrorists or terrorists that if you
resisted it would be worse on you it was
better to give up
they knew exactly what they were doing
and even their flags and [ __ ] they would
fly false Flags
which that's where the word false flag
came from did you see her today it
looked like a British flag until they
got it right next to you and they pulled
a British flag down then they'd set up
some kind of pirate flag psych yeah it'd
be usually something like the devil
holding an hourglass in one hand in your
heart and another they had all different
kinds of that you know it was only a
matter of time and then and really
that's that was the main pirate tactic
was time they would just wear you down
over time until you gave up they would
just dog you yeah and you just couldn't
you couldn't they would just follow the
ship and follow the ship and harass and
harass and harass and try to Grapple and
get and attached to the ship and
eventually board the ship and once they
got on there they did bad [ __ ]
and they were nuts they'd set their hair
on fire have Cannon fuses coming out of
their [ __ ] beard on fire we have
black beardies yeah they all they did
all kinds of weird something put some
matches their selves on fire and jump in
you know because they had different they
put a [ __ ] leather difficult thick
leather clothing on and [ __ ]
cover it with [ __ ] oil and set it on
fire and [ __ ] jump into the ship and
just to be crazy you know they're
[ __ ] crazy but they were pretty good
evidently they successfully took a lot
of ships
they did yeah I mean they got a lot of
stuff so my chismo had a lot to do with
this too making money
I didn't get money and being tough
I was gonna say too the whole wooden leg
thing they said that's probably not too
crazy either because there are records
of like many different pirates that got
various limbs shot off during battles
legs arms and whatnot yeah first aid
wasn't what it is today well yeah they
basically just had they just had the
cook coming like hey got a Cleaver yeah
then like [ __ ] then they just burn it
closed yeah but that made a lot of sense
because they had so much so many
problems with uh well you know infection
there was no
um
antibiotics so if you had a a wound like
a bullet bullet wound and it went closed
a lot of times it would Fester
especially at Sea where it was [ __ ]
filthy
so yeah can you imagine what some of
those [ __ ] ships like probably
smelled like so above that wound going
through the arm was more dangerous than
cutting the arm off
sounds [ __ ] contrary but no true
because a wound would close up and it
would be all [ __ ] festered in there
it was easier to have for a clean cut
yeah and then you could cauterize it
or some of them were good they would
just
cut the arm off and make a slit peel the
meat back off the bone a little bit and
[ __ ] snap that bone off and then
[ __ ] pour a bunch of alcohol on it
[ __ ] fry you know pour some rum on it
and then they'd roll all that meat
forward and [ __ ] try to Dime sew it
back together and pour it and rum and
let that heal up you know
which they did that without anesthesia
yeah but
I had this arm reset without anesthesia
just pulling on it you can get you can
get yourself pretty [ __ ] tough you
know
plus you're already hurt so if they're
working fast it's it's numb
you know and uh evidently they didn't
think anything about wrapping a damn bit
of leather belt around somebody's
Knuckles and just knocking you out and
then
working real fast which that would
probably be that would probably be
better it's like well we don't have any
anesthesia so knock his ass
can you be like that maybe cut your arm
off during that time oh thank you oh man
yeah
just sweet spot you're right in the jaw
which that that's what I tell to do
take a couple big belts of damn booze
knock me out bro
get to work
hurry up get that off yeah and they were
working on dudes with [ __ ] tools that
weren't sanitary
you know they might [ __ ] touch flame
through it to it
uh but uh they had just gotten done
working on somebody you knew right next
to you yeah so yeah oh wow
well they're like hey you guys been
living in the same ship for a long time
you've probably traded Journeys yeah
life expectancy what it wasn't what it
was too back then yeah Pirates didn't uh
live too long generally if I remember
correctly I think they the average one
only existed only lived for about three
years I think before he was killed yeah
I think it was something like three to
five years like once they joined no they
didn't they usually got killed in battle
or you know infected somethings or you
know or they were captured and [ __ ]
executed
mm-hmm also um
there was an advantage to being on a
crew pirate crew
pirate Crews allowed women and Imperial
ships didn't
uh also the
um discipline on an imperial ship was uh
a lot of harsher
um not on a pirate ship it was a little
more practical they were a little more
forgiving about things like being drunk
on duty and uh you know falling asleep
they were pretty they were because you
were everyone was considered to be a
private or Privateer you were there
voluntarily so it's not like they were
forcing you so they kind of it was kind
of like a feeling of [ __ ]
professionalism and Brotherhood now if
you [ __ ] up they would punish you but
the punishment may not have been as as
uh as ruthless as it would have been on
an imperial ship like I don't think
they'd be Keel hauling and things like
that or making people [ __ ] walk the
planks like they did
although they did do that
but you had to be I think a very serious
offender
I I read that they didn't that walking
the plank was largely like a myth what
was execution yeah
you know
um
I know that they would kill Hall yeah
which if you guys know what that is
they'd tie a
a line to your hands and your feet and
throw you down underneath the Keel and
have the ship go over you whatever
Barnacles on there so if it all Cuts you
up and then it'd pull you up over the
other side
you'd be all [ __ ] cut up by the time
they got you out of there pretty bad
seems like a lot of trouble when they
could just as easily like just beat the
crap out of you on the ship well they
also just whipped you that's what I'm
saying that seems much easier give the
amount of lashes well British ships were
known for that
yeah and it was over pretty minor
infractions too
but you know the British impressed
people into service they just [ __ ]
you just draft you you know a lot of
those guys weren't there voluntarily
they weren't really professionals
it's just no choice they just took you
you know yeah they got Shanghai
yeah and then um
weird things like cabin boys
uh which we're supposed to be boys but
my understanding most cabin boys were
actually girls
girls dressed as boys but that's how you
snuck him onto the ship
that makes sense yeah
yeah I was gonna I was gonna say
something but I forgot what it was
that was related oh I think women
weren't allowed on ships except pirate
ships
yeah they were even female captains I
believe yeah there were some um
it would kind of work their way up to
the ranks
and don't be uh they weren't good either
though I think it was Calico Jack had
two of them didn't he two girlfriends
I don't know and I think it's what it
was I think it was he had two
girlfriends and when he died I think
they be one of them became Captain for a
while but then they they pretty much all
I think the two girls got off
um one of they were they got sentenced
to death I think in Puerto Rico or Haiti
I forgot
and uh both of them were pregnant so
they gotta they got away with it or at
least they both claim to be pregnant I
don't remember that was probably
something he did back then if you were
gonna get executed yeah you just claim
to be pregnant
but um yeah there were a lot of female
pirates and now they were really
associated with Florida all that much
but I remember I was reading
um something about just like piracy all
over the world and they said actually
one of the most formidable uh pirate
captains in Asia was I believe a Chinese
woman she had like a [ __ ] massive
Fleet of like pirate ships and she was
one of the most powerful pirates of the
time but yeah so but there were there
were some those are the ones that Disney
tried to include but then the Chinese
government says no you can't make us
look like Pirates isn't that isn't that
the one that lived here I mean there's
well I don't know but um her name was
Mrs Chang okay but um I mean there are
pirates everywhere Pirates aren't just I
know everybody knows Pirates of the
Caribbean which is kind of what we're
talking about but
everywhere has Pirates they still have
Pirates nowadays yeah you know if you
like are a rich person and you're out in
your yacht one day and come across
some Pirates they're gonna come on there
and take all your [ __ ] in America the
most famous pirates are basically
British Pirates and French Pirates yeah
I mean I feel like what I was gonna say
was that um somewhere between like 80
and 95 percent of pirates were
originally Like official like Navy they
were in their navies or whatever their
country is mostly English a lot of them
were English but yeah there was like
some French ones too granddaddy a mall
in American culture would be Blackbeard
which uh I think he was from I think he
was actually from Ireland if I remember
correctly uh but he was considered to be
British although if you actually Trace
where he lived you mostly Living in
America
well kind of more like an american guy
but uh you know America was different
back then it was part of the British
Empire
but he was probably the granddaddy
Blackbeard
he's a pretty good pirate yeah
like I said he doesn't have all that
much to do with Florida although
um one pirate that was on his crew for a
time did have something to do with
Florida so we'll get into that okay in a
little bit
too much about well yeah I mean I had a
couple of uh shout outs all right I
think uh hey you want to say like thanks
for your shirt that you have oh yeah
getting got a shirt from Mexico here
yeah my boy said that to me Keith
yeah
also known as murder Hornets it's a
top-notch embroidered Harley-Davidson
shirt from Mexico yeah it's embroidered
yeah oh it's fancy yeah yeah and he also
sent me that um that skeleton Brian I
think I put her back there though
already because she was right there
earlier but I showed her on her earlier
I don't think murder Hornets is on there
I haven't seen him no he's not so far I
haven't seen him
uh but also I want to give a big thanks
to Miguel for sending me a PayPal
donation earlier today or yesterday I
think it was so thank you very much for
that and I think that's probably all is
that all the shout outs that we have
today yeah I wanted to remind everybody
to go and subscribe to my scare Salon
Channel I just posted another video over
there today like earlier today which is
about the weird British sci-fi movie
extra
so go over there and check it out if you
haven't I posted about it on the um
Community tab but you know
yeah John Smith said Blackbeard's first
mate was called Israel hands
Robert Louis Stevenson used his name as
a character in Treasure Island yep
that's right that's right
um yeah murder Hornet said I'm here just
laying down listening oh okay
Mr 88 said yes Somalia has been doing a
ton of pirating lately and they tend to
kill everyone yeah somehow it's just
kind of like I guess because the pirates
of old
um because it's so far distant in time
and we've had like all this fun like
Treasure Island and Pirates of Penzance
and then now and more recently the
Pirates of the Caribbean movies and
stuff so I feel like people have like a
more romantic uh conception of pirates
like that like if you talk about the
Somali pirates there's like well that's
that's not as fun you know what I mean I
mean but like back then it probably
wasn't fun either like if you were on a
ship and your [ __ ] [ __ ] got attacked
by Pirates you'd probably be hating life
yeah I've seen a lot of videos Smalley
Pirates getting ate the [ __ ] up too
they'll just come up in a damn motorboat
with a bunch of AKs and RPGs
trying to uh
I guess take some kind of a superior
vessel and they just chew them up
[ __ ] 50 cows
so they don't always know what they're
doing
I think that was actually something kind
of like a Navy vessel that they once
tried to take
because it looked military they just
[ __ ] chopped that boat up
so
they bit off more than they could chew
yes it happens
granther says the biker babes at the
Oasis will think your shirt is dope oh
yeah
yeah I was actually thinking about going
but I just don't feel right yet
yeah don't go spread your cooties
[Laughter]
yeah you haven't been in a while a
couple weeks
yeah every time I show back up every
time I show up and it's been a while
since I've been there they [ __ ] start
freaking out where the hell you been and
a bunch of free drinks come and
everything
hmm well that's good if you leave like
long enough in between yeah so nobody
feels like you're just showing up every
day yeah because they live in those
places yeah you know
where are you loser yeah
the music will get to you you know
that's probably why I never so
but I got that damn app so I can bypass
their music and start the damn
uh jukebox so I was putting all kinds of
[ __ ] on there what was funny is that the
girls like it though
yeah because they're they're kind of
sick of that country
I can't blame them so I would just start
spinning some stuff that we maybe here
at ibar yeah you know oh yeah I like
that one I put [ __ ] uh Boys Don't Cry
from The Cure around there
so they know the same music just they
don't get to hear it all the time well
yeah they're probably our age aren't
they yeah they're our age
slasher Fred said if you guys ever
watched that movie The Princess Bride
that's a great [ __ ] movie by the way
uh the character of Wesley is also a
pirate That's right The Dread pirate
Roberts The Dread pirate Roberts that's
like a whole
right you've never seen that movie have
you oh it's good it's really good uh
mrady you forgot the pirate movie with
Chrissy McNichol I wish I could forget
it no seriously that movie
I saw that was one of those movies that
was on like every day it seemed like on
Cinemax or whatever
uh and for whatever reason when I was a
kid or and a teenager I loved it
uh it's actually it's the Pirates of
Penzance is what it is but they didn't
call it that and they changed the story
around a little bit and they changed
some of the songs like they put more
contemporary pop songs in there I
haven't seen it a long time but I'm sure
I'm always kind of like afraid to watch
it again because I used to love it so
much when I was a kid even though I knew
it was bad like even back then but I'm
like I'd probably watch it nowadays and
just like [ __ ] cringe the whole
[ __ ] time yeah I I don't I give two
shits for [ __ ] pirate movies all
right there's really only one pirate
movie that I like it has Michael Caine
in it and it's called the island and
it's a Florida movie about [ __ ]
pirates in the modern era in the 80s
they find some old pirates that were
living out it's based on a book
and Michael K
it takes his son out to the keys for a
vacation
and they fall they fall into this
[ __ ] trap that was laid
by some pirates that were living in a
[ __ ] Island out there in the Keys
and they're the descendants of real
pirates from this era and they're still
out there doing it and for the modern
world has left them behind they're still
their their speech is still like
something out of the 1600s
they're using mixture of old weapons and
and and and you know like and modern
weapons and they're stealing stuff and
you know Raiden [ __ ]
uh sailboats and getting their hands on
cocaine and doing all kinds of weird
[ __ ] it's a good movie called The Island
from I think it's 1980 I think
and if you guys haven't seen it go ahead
and check it out that's one of the best
pirate movies
and evidently there are some
uh [ __ ] regulars who follow the show
have read the book they said the book is
even better did Peter bashley write it I
don't know the same guy that wrote y'all
I don't know or am I just certainly
pulling that out of my butt but it's got
Michael Caine and it's got the dude from
uh [ __ ] who played uh David Warner
David Warner a guy who played massive
control from Tron he's in it and Jack
the Ripper from time after time yeah but
yeah yeah
and um
yeah it's [ __ ] it's a good flick
they're running out of women and they're
all inbreeding too in there because
yeah and they're [ __ ] still trying to
go through this whole book and [ __ ]
talk about just Dr Brazil and yeah it's
pretty good Grandpa's Hammer that was
called uh Cutthroat Island that movie
that you're thinking of what the name of
the pirate movie that killed both the
careers of Matthew Modine and Gina Davis
although Matthew Modine came back he's
on stranger things now but yeah yeah
that I think it was called Cutthroat
Island I didn't see it Muppet Treasure
Island yeah that's another good pirate
movie see there you go there's good
pirate movies
I mean everything with the Muppets in it
is good come on I mean Muppets Take
Manhattan is probably my favorite well I
don't know
actually no I think the great Muppet
Caper is my favorite but Muppet Treasure
Island is good too and Muppet Christmas
Carol is also good
Hugo said uh I just saw the island with
Michael Kane for the first time is a
good movie yeah uh Dave's here hey he
also loves Muppet Treasure Island yeah
[ __ ] the uh the island with uh
Michael Kane
is actually a movie when you actually
peel it back it's a movie about
masculinity and fatherhood
about how
modern dads
cannot offer what ancient dads could
offer all this damn [ __ ] high
adventure but then Michael K being a
Korean War veteran
in the end
no it was better than what their pirate
Dad could offer now he's like what the
[ __ ] is a dad hire it Dad wait
he had captured they had cap they were
capturing children and raising them to
become members of their pirate band
and they captured Michael Kane's son and
got him to [ __ ] adopt a new pirate
identity to Barb
and he almost killed his own dad yeah
that's right yeah but in the end uh
[ __ ] his dad [ __ ] had skills that
pirates didn't have once he got hold of
that [ __ ] m250 and [ __ ] cut those
dudes down on the back of that down
Coast Guard [ __ ] [ __ ] on a coast
guard ships on the back way I think it
was a [ __ ] Oliver Perry class [ __ ]
missiles Cruiser [ __ ] him up it's a
good movie good movie it is good oh it's
a forgotten classic
I got it on Blu-ray
best pirate movie out there
captain crazy says is the island related
to the movie the island with Steve
Buscemi is that a remake I don't think
so I haven't seen that but I don't I'd
never heard that the island got remade
but it's possible that it that it
absolutely it would never remake the
island
well I don't know about that they remake
everything else they might get around to
it it didn't it didn't succeed back in
the day and I think that might have been
the same guy who wrote Jaws I think
that's right yeah if somebody did say it
was yeah yeah that's right it's a it
evidently it was the book was even
better
I wouldn't mind reading it actually I
did yeah and I will say I read the book
of Jaws and I didn't love it the movie's
way better yeah which I don't usually
say like 99 of the time the book is
better but Jaws I think the movie is
better but I could vouch for the movie
The Island though Michael Kane 1980.
kind of like the sequel The Unofficial
sequel to Jaws real good
captain we still haven't watched Jaws
for yeah yeah I looked it up and I was
just like well it's not really free we
got to pay to watch it and I'm like I
don't know if I wanted so it's it's I
remember it being funny but you know
what I mean already holy crap
Lord of the Flies yeah I mean you know
now I'm trying to think of uh yeah the
great Muppet Caper was another movie
that was always on cable in the early
80s yeah that's right and Oracle said
Muppets make everything better I agree
grandfather's Hammer Jimmy Buffett has a
song called a pirate looks at 40. a
pirate looks at 40 which he still sings
at age 80.
is Jimmy Buffett still alive Jesus
Christ man I've told that Jimmy Buffett
story about how the guy I used to work
for he was like the world's biggest
Jimmy Buffett fan holy [ __ ]
I'm just like uh
if I had to hear that [ __ ] CD one
more time I don't know what would have
[ __ ] happened I'm like I'm just gonna
like explode or do something
uh yeah the fog that also had kind of
pirates in it they were pirates weren't
they in the fog
yeah I guess they were
see Pirates are cool I mean you know
yeah that's what we were just talking
about Dave we were just talking about uh
Jaws 4 the other day
because I saw it in the theater actually
when it first came out
um but Tom's never seen it and I was
like you got to see jaws for it's like
so awful I don't even think it's as bad
okay I think Jaws 3 is worse but I
haven't seen Jaws for in a long time so
I'm willing to concede that Jaws 4 might
be worse but Michael Kane is in it and
it's just like the premise of it is just
so ridiculous like that the shark is
like smart enough to like I'm gonna
follow you [ __ ] all the way
down to [ __ ] Florida Michael Caine
knew how to be in the movie though he
based on his movie based on what hotel
you're gonna stay in well yeah that's
right we went that was his whole like uh
that was his whole ammo he knew he's
doing
and you guys if any of you guys are
British they wasn't there like a little
kids cartoon show about a pirate called
Captain pug wash
I remember there was a little thing that
was called Captain pug wash because I
used to always think that was like the
funniest pirate name ever
but yeah see that's what I mean it's
just it just seems like nowadays Pirates
are like
Kids characters you know what I mean
even though back in the day I mean
they're
they're kind of like uh rapists and
murderers and Wanderers and [ __ ] it's
just kind of funny
yeah see I'm good I'm I'm glad that I'm
a good influence on you people making
y'all watch the island Hugo said yeah
you just saw it it's a good movie it is
a good movie it's a forgotten classic
if you haven't seen it you got to see it
John Smith says it's like watching Jaws
yeah just like Jaws but it's Pirates
Jaws but with pirates yeah yeah Mr 88
said no Jaws the Revenge is worse okay
I'll I'll take your word for it like I
said I've seen Jaws 3 much more recently
than I've seen Jaws for so I don't
remember like I said I saw Jasper in the
theater and I maybe saw it on cable
after that one time but I don't think
I've seen it since then
um yeah John Smith Jaws 4 with a roaring
shark and Michael Kane who can only get
hot for Widow [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
get hot for specifically widows whose
husbands were killed by sharks
because did Brody get killed by a shark
or no
now I can't remember or did he just die
of like a heart attack or something
boring I don't remember
he didn't go out like a g he didn't go
out like [ __ ] Quint getting eaten by
the shark I can't remember yeah
yeah it's funny how how over time that
they have kind of evolved and being
children's characters yeah and they were
gonna like they were [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] I went seriously the enemies of
mankind I went to because Saint
Augustine because you know you last year
like I said I went on vacation like for
five days or something and I went to St
Augustine where I've been lots of times
it's a it's a really cool place and
there's a lot of pirate lore around it
because and I'll get into that in a bit
because Saint Augustine was like at the
core of like a lot of pirate [ __ ] that
happened here
and there is a pirate and treasure
Museum in Saint Augustine and they it's
cool because they have like a lot of
displays of stuff that they found in
shipwrecks like from around the state
and whatnot but the museum
I mean it's a regular Museum but it's
very much geared toward children and
when I was there and I think it was June
so it was summertime and school was out
that place was like [ __ ] packed with
kids packed with kids yeah and they have
like all kind of like kid friendly stuff
for them to do like on top of all the
other stuff but one of the coolest
things they have in there other than all
the stuff from the shipwrecks is they
actually have one I believe of only
three surviving Jolly Roger
you know there's the iconic like job
they they have one there and it's
actually like in pretty decent shape
for as old as it is it doesn't look
quite as badass I mean it looks very
homemade obviously which it was it
doesn't look quite as badass as the ones
nowadays but they made that [ __ ] up as
they were going along yeah yeah
everything kind of was like that I just
think it's funny how
how their lore has been blown imagine
Pirates are probably laugh they probably
laugh if they if they had seen
you know what what
their lore had grown into
you know I mean little kids are into it
they probably just think that was
[ __ ] funny
um I imagine they probably yeah but we
have to [ __ ] reiterate this [ __ ]
if you chose
to partake in the pirate lifestyle
for money and Glory
it would be an elusive Mirage
most of them didn't live but about four
years
so the whole idea about getting rich
you don't live long enough to spend it
I think that's kind of why Pirates were
known for spending like they'd they'd
make a big haul and then they'd be like
whoo they'd go right to the tavern and
the brothel would like just blow it yeah
because they knew they were gonna live
that yeah they would just go party for a
few weeks yeah so it was not like a
long-term life strategy even for the
captains they didn't really live that
long
yeah and uh
it was kind of like as a suicide pact
which tells me that it wasn't really
didn't I don't think it had much to do
with the money
I think it was just uh
it was
lust for adventure it was in it well and
I think some people too didn't really
have any where else to go they really
didn't have anything else to do it's
kind of suicidal you know they would get
a Kamikaze no no there was no other uh
no other life plan for them you know
which is kind of strange when you think
about it because if you had the skills
and the equipment you could just go to
the new world and go walk out [ __ ]
become an Indian which did people did it
all the time yeah and live a lot longer
and have a much better uh [ __ ] uh
lifestyle
than a pirate
if I'd be in a pirate
okay you're out of [ __ ] sea on those
old [ __ ] vessels yeah I don't think
you're crazy I don't think I would like
to yeah I mean it would depend though
it's like if you're if your life was
like way suckier than that like I said a
lot of them were like escaped slaves and
stuff which I'm sure being a pirate was
better than that
but
it was all kind of like I don't know
like I said some people joined a lot of
people did join voluntarily so I imagine
that some people's circumstances in life
were shitty enough that they were kind
of like yeah I'm gonna try this [ __ ] out
early I joined US Army Airborne during
wartime to go to the first Gulf War I
[ __ ] love risk and adventure
but you got to mitigate that [ __ ] with
reality and what projected lifespans are
about you
and um
modern Naval service is boring I
wouldn't do it I [ __ ] it I don't really
I respect it but I wouldn't do it uh
it's not as dangerous as it was and
you're on ships all the time and no
thanks I'm not a big fan of the ocean I
want to be on the land yeah you know and
if I'm on not on the land I want to be
flying you know I love [ __ ] Air
flight aircraft and being at Shoppers
and stuff
ch-47s and [ __ ] c-130s and [ __ ] C5
galaxies and
747s and
mountain climbing and hiking and doing
infantry [ __ ] I [ __ ] love that
if I were to ever choose back in those
days back in the 15 16 17 1800s of what
it was I'd like to do
it's like well look if you want to live
a life of adventure
you know what would you choose it would
not be piracy hell no I joined a [ __ ]
Indian tribe
or something
you live a lot better and you'd live
longer
yeah and you wouldn't every time you
went out you wouldn't have to worry
about getting your [ __ ] face shot off
by the cannon well you're not on a sea
yeah that's white to see but it's not
the sea you can't drown you could always
and there's not sharks yeah
and there's that we need to look at
and there's horsemanship which I [ __ ]
love horses too it was in the horse
industry I could ride jump and do Hunter
Chomper stuff
um
I could re if and if this [ __ ] ever goes
Mad Max and it's the end of cars and
this and that I'll go straight like
something out of the postman [ __ ]
where I can get horses and [ __ ] live
on the back of the horse if I had to
[ __ ] train other people how to do it
at my age I could only really my value
is to be a trainer
and um
no you want to be a [ __ ] planes
Indian
they had it made that was the lifestyle
right there in those days
technology caught up with it though
you know yeah but back then it probably
back then it was good but he just
nowadays you can't run through other
people's properties fences and [ __ ] cars
you know radio
that stopped all that
laws you know
And Justice For Me says in St Augustine
the Pirates couldn't even touch the
Spanish though in terms of Bloodshed
yeah ain't that the truth
um yeah I wanna actually one thing that
I didn't really know that much about but
like when I was in St Augustine last
time
was uh the Spanish
massacring the French huguenots that
came there because like I said they were
Protestants and the Spanish Crown was
Catholic uh so huguenots had set up a
kind of like Outpost with in what is now
Jacksonville in the north part of
Florida and a lot of the Spaniards like
no no can't have that uh so they would
basically go and just like [ __ ] wipe
them out in horrible ways and actually
in Saint Augustine uh they wiped out
like a whole bunch of them like they
just executed all at one time and that's
the reason that that Inlet now is called
matanzas because that means Slaughter so
yeah we I learned that on the tour when
I was there
we did learn like Florida history in
school but I think I forgot a lot of it
because I think most of the Florida
history we learned was mostly probably
like Elementary School and Junior High
and I remember doing a lot of Florida
history in high school but it is like
what because let's talk about cooking
Bacardi used to be my drink but I'm
sober for 15 years is I relive it by
watching you guys yeah
watching us get [ __ ] up yeah
uh yeah
And Justice For Me said they were
absolute criminals they're made out to
be adventurers or they're called
Buccaneers or swashbucklers yeah I think
Buccaneers and I'm kind of get into why
like where that word came from and stuff
like that but that's
yeah I kind of feel like that word now
it sort of like evokes like I said like
swashbuckle like ooh I'm Errol Flynn or
whatever like that I mean Buccaneers you
know what that means the reason the word
Buccaneers comes from
um I think it's an Arawak Indian word
and uh booking and I think the French
like called them and all that was was
just the so we have smoked stuff right
well yeah it was just like the thing
they set up to like smoke meat on yeah
yeah and uh you know some of the people
that yeah that's basically what it was
like from [ __ ] Water World right
smokers and because some of the people
that were associated with piracy like
use that same method like with it as the
Arawak Indians then they started calling
them Buccaneers so smoking meat
and I mean Tampa Bay they're uh their
football team obviously is called the
Buccaneers Tampa Bay Buccaneers
I don't think Ponce de Leon could be
considered a pirate though
well mostly on was more kind of like a
like a
more kind of like a conquistador in a
way he was an Explorer but yeah more
like a conquistador
which there's something I mean that's is
that like a distinction without a
difference though I mean I kind of feel
like we'll pirate has a pretty specific
has a pretty specific definition in the
sense that you're on a ship and you're
targeting other ships that are carrying
cool [ __ ] yeah and taking their [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty much the definition
of pirate a privateer is somebody that's
doing that but has the official sanction
of a government or the royal family or
whatever to do that but it's still doing
pirate [ __ ] all my Mexican friends in
there mad me talking about the
Conquistadors but look
all y'all down there in Central and
South America you know you know I grew
up in the culture you're all a bland of
the Maya and and the conquistadoris from
the from the LA conquista [ __ ] if you
if you actually look at Central and
South American history it's like some
fantasy written by 15 year old boys okay
they were all badasses
they were just all it's like something
at a damn Star Trek okay
um
the conquistadors were cool too okay
just kind of landless Nobles
trying to make a name for themselves in
a new world
Mary and local women and
trying to figure out a place for
themselves that didn't last long though
you know it was just one of the things
that happened
it was immigration they're just
immigrating that's
[Laughter]
too bad there were people already there
it's always that way though it's so
they're always people oh this is our
[ __ ] now bye there's always people
already there it's just well not always
back in those days history was always
like that but you know
I don't know I don't think that's cool
yeah it was well I know that the way
history goes it's just well it's always
yeah but saying like oh that's the way
it is or I don't think that's cool those
are two separate ideas nothing's cool
nothing is cool if you look at a certain
extent well you can look at the toltecs
and the total Tech statues there they
weren't from here
those toe Tech looked
those are Islanders if you ask me
looking at those heads those aren't
mesoamericans so everybody was coming
here for tens of thousands of years in
different
successive waves of immigration and or
migration you know immigration is
something only from the that concept
comes from the era of the nation-state
this is before nation states people
moved around this is the way it was
but uh you look at the the mesoamericans
that the conquistadors were dealing with
were or an ad mixture they were already
mixed from centuries before
uh because they were just a mixture of
things from all over the world
and you look at the total Tech statues
man some of them say well that look kind
of like the Maori
but you could also say they might have
been African
because there are Africanized looking
people on little islands all out the
world the Africans didn't stay on Africa
they they were semen too they [ __ ]
were sailing in [ __ ] conquering new
lands and islands and
just everybody moved everybody was
always moving
just the way it is humans humans you
know it's how they are evil hairless
monkeys but that's what you're supposed
to be
somebody asked what uh Pirates were
going to be talking about probably going
to cover I mean hopefully if I get
around to it yeah Sir Francis Drake who
was a privateer yeah uh Robert Searle
Henry Jennings Black Caesar and uh Jose
Gaspar who is probably not a real guy
but I want to get into him because so
much of the culture of modern day Tampa
is tied up in the legend about him so I
kind of want and where the legend came
from and I thought that was really
interesting so I wanted to get into that
as well
um but yeah I think there was like
something else that I wanted to answer
oh Danny Rowling said it would be sick
if Juan Ponce de Leon actually
discovered a fountain of youth who was
still alive
how [ __ ] hilarious would that be I've
been to the Fountain of Youth
the or at least like the park that he
saw like he never found it obviously
because there's no such thing but
basically there is it's like a Sulfur
Spring is what it is and it's in St
Augustine they have it you can go and I
didn't go this last time but I've been
there before you can just go in there
and like drink from it and there's like
little mummified bodies the concrete the
conquistadors were [ __ ] fascinating
they were looking for a lot of things
they were looking for the Fountain of
Youth they were looking for the City of
Gold what was that El Dorado they were
looking
you can't judge these people by modern
standards they were being heavily
motivated by Legend and religion and
just things that they dreamed up
it is quite fascinating like I said
most of human history was like it was
written by a 15 year old boy
[Laughter]
it's hilarious yes I'm gonna find the
place where water comes out of the
ground if you drink it you stay young
forever
laughs
that feels like it's funny to me that's
like some of it they believe that yeah
it's just funny it's like someone 15
year old boy would think like you would
actually like go ahead and I don't know
there's any money on this I mean to be
honest I don't think that was his only
goal he's like oh maybe if I find it
cool but he's like I think that he was
like looking for other [ __ ] like [ __ ]
who knows gold and slaves and [ __ ] like
they all were back then well they were
looking to profit that's what I'm saying
it when they were Mercenaries but I'm
not saying that he didn't believe in it
and he's like ooh if I find out about it
I'm gonna go check that [ __ ] out yeah
like he probably did but I don't know if
he I don't think he did the whole thing
just for that because
um you know Ferdinand and Isabella they
like backed up his [ __ ] or no I'm
talking about Christopher Columbus
but I'm just talking about he you know
he had like um people behind him that
were like well no you're you're no
you're looking at it through Modern Eyes
the Modern Eyes of rationality and
reason no no
the first emperor of China was sending
people out into the ocean to come back
and find the same goddamn thing a
[ __ ] test some kind of a liquid metal
you could drink that would keep you
[ __ ] young forever
Mercury try that mercury yeah yeah
Mercury and see how long that lives yeah
yeah
so no no
no they were dumb well not dumb
people will believe all kinds of crazy
things you know what I mean and they
have always believed in crazy things
yeah no kidding and uh they'll have the
money and the power of nation states or
tribes and kingdoms and they'll [ __ ]
diverted I want you to build the baddest
[ __ ] Navy you could ever [ __ ]
think of with all this high-tech [ __ ]
even steam engines go out and try to
find the [ __ ] the elixir of ever
everlasting life
oh [ __ ] and then they put you on that
task
yeah to go out and find that no people
believed in ridiculous [ __ ] and they
still do just that we don't we don't
think it's ridiculous
you know but
centuries from now
they will look back at us and [ __ ]
laugh at us
for believing what we believe in
yeah
I don't think it's yeah we we fantasize
about more realistic [ __ ] than we used
to but no 200 years from now people are
going to laugh at us
for being simpletons you know
but in a way that's good because that's
like progress yeah you're right that's
just how it works you know what I mean
right it's all right
all right so I'm out of ice already okay
ice melted I'll refresh that whole thing
for you okay yeah might as well while
you're up and I can actually start the
show start the show because we have so
much to get through because like I said
even though I didn't get as much
research in as I wanted to but I did
manage to get like quite a bit and I'm
sure I left some [ __ ] out but oh I found
this great video on YouTube that
actually was really helpful because it
helped me like kind of structure because
whenever I do a show like this I get
like really excited like to do the topic
but then when I actually get to research
it I'm like oh [ __ ] there's like 40
million things like all over the place
it's like what am I gonna cover what am
I gonna leave out
um so I found this really cool lecture
and it was from earlier this year and I
think it was from the um Tampa the
history museum that they have over there
which I've been to a couple times and I
used to live over there
and they had a talk last January this
past January by um a guy who had written
a book about Florida Pirates and he gave
like an hour-long presentation about it
and it was really really interesting
like he dressed up like a pirate too
which that's kind of his thing he's like
a living history type of guy
um but yeah he actually gave a really
interesting talk and that was like so I
listened to that earlier and I was like
that was a really good in like helping
me like structure my notes and like
figure out what I should put in and what
I should leave out and stuff like that I
also read another book I found it on uh
uh Kindle unlimited which I think is
just called the Florida
what's it called Florida pirate history
or the pirate history of Florida or
something like that it's not really a
book it was like more like a pamphlet I
think it was only like 40 50 pages but
that kind of went into a lot of stuff
but I was kind of like look to scant at
it a little bit because
he talked about Jose Gaspar as though he
was a real person and I'm pretty sure
99.99 of historians have come to the
conclusion that Jose Gaspar was not a
real person was like natural pirate
um like I said I still want to talk
about him anyway uh to want to talk
about the legend because it's tied in so
much with Tampa with like Tampa's
history they still have the Gasparilla
Festival
which is kind of like Mardi Gras but
pirate themed and they do that pretty
much every year like around the same
time as Mardi Gras I think it's from
like January to March they have all got
a big pirate parade and it's like it's a
huge huge [ __ ] deal so and it's all
based on I mean I think they kind of
know that it's based on like not a real
guy but there's like a lot of Legends
about the guy so I kind of want to get
into that at the end if I have time uh
so we'll try to do that like I said I'm
trying to keep it to Florida so some of
the Pirates were talking about did some
other [ __ ] like in other places but I
don't want to go too much into that
because I'm trying to keep it more
florida-centric if that makes anything
you hit that like but like button if you
guys uh can some guys some of you guys
are on Smart TVs and can't do it but
yeah because I think the more likes that
it has the more likely it is to be
recommended to other people right yeah I
mean I well the thing about it is like
this this Channel and my new channel
they still get recommended to people
because pretty much every day or every
other day I'm still getting messages
from oh my God I just found this channel
okay and uh you know oh my God you're
talking about this movie or whatever
sometimes it's like our old videos or
sometimes it's more recent ones so
people are still like jumbling across it
which is good but like I said I talked
earlier about we're still still a small
Channel though
yeah relatively I mean you know there's
I mean we're bigger than a lot of other
horror channels that I like but or we're
about the same size as some of them but
I was talking earlier about maybe moving
my flickers of fear in terms of Terror
uh series like over to the new channel
but I'm not gonna do that until the new
channel has enough views subscribers
stuff like that to monetize it because
at the moment you know I can monetize
those videos on this channel but I can't
monetize anything you found us because
of a book review
well there you go what book was it do
you remember were you the one that said
it was House of leaves
I remember somebody said that it was
House of leaves
I should probably I don't know it's like
I always kind of feel like maybe I
should cover more
stuff that's well known like to get
people but then I was like well then
there's like so much competition and a
lot of times when I do something like
really weird and obscure like I get a
lot of people being like Oh my God I
can't believe I thought I was the only
person that saw this movie or read this
book or whatever so I don't know it's
kind of it's kind of hard that's why I
kind of like just try to cover
everything and like let the chips fall
where they make yeah it was House of
leaves that's right I remember you
saying that but yeah
um and I feel like I reviewed that book
and I didn't even like scratch the
surface I just you know but I feel that
about all my videos I'm like oh my God I
didn't like cover what I wanted to cover
I don't know I have problems uh all
right so Florida in particular uh very
very rich history of pirates both real
and legendary as we'll get into in a bit
so probably the cities and the areas
most commonly associated with piracy at
least in Florida I mean it happened all
over the state but Saint Augustine is a
big one uh the so-called Treasure Coast
which it wasn't called that until later
after they found like some big wrecks
there and that's pretty much where it's
like from Port St Lucie down the lake so
Miami-Dade kind of areas like on the
East Coast uh also got the Florida Keys
obviously uh and Tampa on the Gulf Coast
Tampa is very very pirate
very pirate-centric City and that's on
the Gulf of Mexico in case you didn't
know
uh so yeah very Pirates of the Caribbean
area
so uh we think maybe the estimate is
that between
1715 and 1726 there were uh reportedly
about 5 000 Pirates sailing the Florida
Straits and the Gulf Coast looking out
for those Spanish galleons and all of
their treasure ships because the thing
about Florida that made it such an
attractive pirate Haven was that
when you had the Spanish that came in
they loaded up all the all the booty
that they got from you know Central and
South America gold silver whatever the
hell
and then they would have to like come
around Florida like and they'd usually
like stop in Havana or they were going
and then go around and like up to The
Atlantics to go back to Europe
so all around the coasts of Florida they
were like that was really really good
places to have like pirate bases because
particularly around the Tampa area and
on the east coast of Florida as well
there's tons and tons of like little
islands and little inlets and like
little Bays like Inland bays and stuff
and so there was a lot of places for
pirates to hide and the thing about it
too was that pirates
even though I kind of feel like because
of the movies you have like the popular
conception of this big like massive
pirate ship in general Pirates liked
smaller ships yeah uh one because they
were faster and two because their hulls
were shallower so you could go in like
shallower water so like if there was a
bigger ass ship like chasing you you
could go into like some Inlet and they
couldn't find you because they would run
around you see they called them sloops
yeah yeah I think it's now I'm not sure
I'm not super up on like Maritime uh
terminology but I think a Sloop is what
like one or two mess right if it's more
than that then it's like a ship yeah
that's at least that's what there's a
small Nimble ship that you could order
another ship you you could use it to
board another ship
because they they eventually wanted a
board
yeah that's right good and and here's
the thing there on TV they're always
showing you showing them going after
some kind of a warship that's not what
they were looking for they were looking
for cargo ships yeah so well yeah that
was their whole thing that's where yeah
they wanted a cargo so you didn't need
um a heavily armed ship because you the
last thing you want to do is to sink the
ship
he didn't want to sink the enemy ship
you're trying to board it and to steal
as much as you could and if this and if
if the cargo vessel was any good you
wanted to steal the ship too yeah
because even if you didn't use the
actual ship you could actually
disassemble the ship and use that to
like for other [ __ ] and if it was loaded
full of a bunch of what they call booty
you couldn't put that on the Sloop yeah
you had to keep it in the ship
so you had to steal the ship and take it
somewhere to an island
offloaded and trying to [ __ ] fence
all that stuff you know they knew they
had it down to a science they knew
exactly what they were doing oh yeah big
time yeah so this whole thing you know
[ __ ] like a pirate ship looks like a
Spanish Galleon and they're trying to
and it's filled with cannons and they're
shooting cannons no that they didn't
want that shooting cannons would sink
the ship which was totally
counterproductive you wanted to steal
the ship
a lot more dangerous yeah a lot more
dude I mean now they did if they did
capture a small ship that they were
going to use for pirating purposes then
they would outfit it with more weapons
yeah they didn't have any yeah but in
general they tended to like smaller
ships because like I said they were more
maneuverable they were faster you could
um hide them in place if someone was out
like looking for you they could
outmaneuver like the bigger ships and
they didn't like cannons in the way that
people think if they took if they if
they had Canon they didn't like ball
because ball would sink the enemy ship
they'd fill it full of shot which was
like buckshot and that way you could
kill people on the crew enemy crewman
you didn't want to sink the ship
the enemy you know you didn't want to
sink the enemy ship so they were turning
cannon into things kind of like big old
large bore
shotguns
you know you put a bunch of [ __ ] lead
shot in it I hope I'm making sense to
you people I'm kind of drunk but uh
my God and we're only like yeah he's
gonna be let's just start yeah we're
just you're gonna be like ranting like
Nicholas Cage not Vampire's Kiss by the
end it's not it's not like in a Disney
movie where they're taking a Spanish
Galleon with a whole bunch of [ __ ]
Cannon and putting [ __ ] ball in the
cannon and shooting it at the enemy ship
that was the last thing they wanted to
do
okay because they did not want to sink
that ship it was more common to have
small cannon up on the top of the slope
filled with shot which is like little
[ __ ]
lead beads so they could kill crewmen on
the other ship
they didn't want to punch a hole in the
ship you know yes like we could use that
yeah they want that chip
they're they're thieves they're not
soldiers they're trying to take
everything they see
yeah that's basic that's their whole
like reason for existing right yeah uh
Hugo said do you have a link to the new
channel I you know I don't at the moment
but I will uh
uh link it in the description I should
start doing that like from now on I keep
forgetting like I have been linking the
videos like in the community tab of this
channel just until like I get people
over there to subscribe to it but you
know
mr88 said you used to talk about Beijing
but I haven't heard her mentioned in a
while just curious now beijing's
downstairs yeah she's still around she's
just uh she doesn't come up here much
she's she's like Queen of the downstairs
yeah
um so she doesn't come upstairs because
Pookie will beat her up yeah she's on
she's on all kinds of uh kidney therapy
though she's getting old she's 12 years
old 12 or 13. so
I had it she's been throwing up so so
she's got a bunch of kidney medicine to
keep her going
um but we'll see I mean I hope she's she
still seems like yeah I still wake up in
the middle of the night and hear her
like crying to her little babies she's
gonna she has a test She's Gotta Do
[ __ ] in a couple weeks and then once
she gets done with that blood test I'm
gonna start giving her some of my
testosterone
I am
because she's losing too much weight
yeah she has been throwing up a lot so
I'm gonna put her on steroids
try to get her to bulk up some
yeah
when you have animals that have and you
know I got friends who are doctors and
[ __ ] when you start clipping the nuts
off of cats or getting them giving them
hysterectomies and [ __ ] they're not
making the amount of [ __ ]
hormones
their their lifespan goes down
by five ten years
because they're not producing they're
not producing the hormones that they
need to [ __ ] regulate body functions
so I'm gonna give her some of my [ __ ]
HRT medicine it only only a couple
a couple CC's per month you know not a
big difference and she seems okay
otherwise I mean she does throw up a lot
but she's always throwing up a lot she's
she's a puker that one
she's always throwing up there's like a
lot of food that doesn't agree with her
so she always has to actually because
she's weak
she has specials it's her kidneys and
her livers yeah she's had that for a
while but yeah she's on medication for
it but you can look at the average
lifespans and animals that have been
fixed do not live as long as animals
that have not been fixed and it's
hormones
but yeah that's you know but like I said
she doesn't we don't see her much
because we don't I mean we're mostly
like upstairs and she doesn't ever come
upstairs because Pookie uh is boss of
upstairs and Pookie will sit and guard
she sits on the ledge like at the top of
the staircase and just sits there like a
little like a little vulture and like
waits to see if Beijing is gonna try and
come upstairs I've been on some of these
chat groups these dudes [ __ ] said my
[ __ ] dog he's looking like [ __ ] I saw
him [ __ ] he's trying to lay down it
looks like his bones are hurting him and
I'm like that [ __ ] is his
Bulldog his pit bull it's been fixed so
he started [ __ ] banging that [ __ ]
pit bull up with his [ __ ]
testosterone he was banging the pit bull
bam banging him up with that [ __ ]
testosterone and that [ __ ] pit bull
got jacked storm to fight all the other
[ __ ] dogs and [ __ ] and came back and
lived another [ __ ] 10 years
yeah
it works it works you know which is a
normal dog's lifespan but not a fixed
dog you know
well we'll see I mean I hope she's gonna
be okay yeah we'll see but after her
test I'm gonna start giving her test
like I said she is a little bit Caster
or Deanna ball
yeah but yeah she has been on medication
for the last few weeks when did we when
was she at the vet
two weeks ago I think it was two weeks
ago yeah she was up about two weeks ago
because she was I don't want to tell a
vet that would be [ __ ] getting it
well yeah but
um what why don't you ask uh our friend
that's a vet
what what he asked Dr Michael wait
Michael yeah I'll ask him
he may not know but
because you know but I mean he is a vet
so yeah you know yeah I mean we have a
friend that's a vet that we met at ever
she's got to pick up weight which that
tells me if I can give her some yeah she
has lost some weight yeah she looks like
she's still two pounds she still looks
which is a line but that's because she's
super fluffy yeah but she lost two
pounds and that's a lot for a kitty for
the cat so I'm gonna get that cat
[ __ ]
what does the cat have to lose
yeah
get up
put that can on [ __ ] steroids
yeah I won't make it I want my kitties
to live forever you're right well I
think that would make that I can't live
another four or five years so I told Tom
I had this I had the weirdest dream
about Pookie the other night I was
carrying Pookie around like a baby which
I do sometimes anyway
and she could talk
cat could talk and the weird thing about
the dream was that I wasn't
Amazed by the fact that she could talk I
was amazed by what she said yeah she
said Daddy has a mustache yeah
the cat was talking about and I mean she
was yeah she was talking about you but
it's like obviously you don't have a
mustache you've never had a mustache I
don't know why like I don't know why
Pokey said that but I was just like wow
she's so smart like I wasn't like holy
[ __ ] she talked since I got sick I've
been sleeping in the man cave on the
ground and I'm fair game for the cat and
Pookie comes and [ __ ] her because I'm
on the ground it's [ __ ] hilarious but
I'm camping out on the ground she's like
wait hey why are you on the ground hey
yes yeah
I'm gonna hit you with my Paws I'll wake
up in the middle of the night and [ __ ]
her face is right next to me are you
awake yeah I'm awake well I'm awake now
[Laughter]
she's cute as [ __ ] yeah
all right so yeah we were talking about
uh ships how Pirates like smaller ships
because for practice for practical
reasons yeah they were practical people
it seemed like they just wanted [ __ ]
that was gonna like help him steal [ __ ]
yeah like fast man they're thieves
that's what I'm saying that was kind of
like their whole their whole thing yeah
okay so the first European uh known to
ex have explored the coast of Florida
obviously Juan Ponce de Leon
who was a Spanish explorer also the
governor of Puerto Rico at the time and
they think that
um he might have gone as far north as
Saint Augustine in 1513 the city wasn't
founded until later but they think that
he did kind of go up there like he said
he was one of the things was probably he
was looking for the Fountain of Youth
and among other things now he was the
one that named the state La Florida he
thought it was an island though uh
because they didn't know and he claimed
it for the Spanish crown
now is that [ __ ] Thunder oh yeah
storm well like I said why are you
surprised it's July yeah we're in
Florida we're in La Florida yeah in the
summer it's like every day it storms
that's just pretty much you just gotta
deal with it uh so yeah
now prior to the founding of the city
which actually didn't happen until about
50 years later
um there had been several attempts and
incursions of other uh you know European
colonization
uh Spain had tried France had tried
um but they were ultimately failed
because Florida it's a big [ __ ] dense
humid horrible swamp so and a lot of it
honestly even back then I mean there
were natives here but um a lot of the
areas were uninhabited because like I
said it was swampy and you know you
couldn't really deal with it it was I
think it was a bit cooler back then but
it was still like pretty miserable
so yeah
so basically what happens
August of 1565.
um there's a fleet of Spanish ships that
shows up on the coast of Florida
and because uh the day that they arrived
was the festival or the feast of Saint
Augustine who was a philosopher and a
bishop
um they decided to name this city where
they found it like they eventually
decided to call it Saint Augustine now
11 days after the ships came like to the
coast
you had an admirable named Admiral named
Pedro Menendez de Aviles and he came on
shore
and he called The Place Saint Augustine
or San Augustine if you wanted if you
would rather and there was actually a
native Village uh nearby so there was
that and if you go to St Augustine
nowadays there's a bunch of stuff like
named after uh Pedro de Aviles a lot of
stuff
so Saint Augustine is I think I
mentioned because I think we did a show
not too long after I came back from
there like ghosts of Saint Augustine so
I might have covered some of this then
but this is mostly pirate [ __ ] so St
Augustine if you don't know is the
oldest continuously occupied European
settlement in the you know the 40 the
contiguous United States
um actually second oldest continually
inhabited city of European origin in the
United States Territory the first being
San Juan Puerto Rico which was actually
founded in 1521 Saint Augustine was
founded as I mentioned in 1565.
now so when at all Pedro I'm just going
to call him Pedro because because we're
tight like that so uh so he basically
took this over for the crown Saint
Augustine this he established the city
now the king says okay so establish a
settlement there cool
um but also along with him and his
brother whose name was Alvaro they're
the ones that sort of developed the
convoy system that was sort of put in
place to bring
Treasures from the new world Central
America South America like other parts
you know Mexico things like that
um this was kind of like they
established the sort of thing that was
going to bring all the treasures where
we're like the way station and then
we're gonna bring all the stuff from the
new world and we're gonna send it on its
way like back to Europe we're looting
the new world and setting it back to
Europe that's what we're doing so he
basically was the captain general of
Spain's treasure Fleet that's what he
was put in charge to do
um and he was also the guy that put
together a bunch of uh ships and stuff
that were sort of
you know would go and like look for
pirates because obviously they're like
look we're gonna have all of these big
Spanish galleons and they're gonna be
going around the state just full of like
gold and silver and all kind of like
cool [ __ ] so obviously Like Pirates are
gonna attack so they had to have like
some system in place like to look out
for that kind of stuff he also as I
mentioned earlier uh was in charge of
rooting out Protestants in the area like
including a settlement of French
huguenots that had taken up residence in
Jacksonville so there was that a lot of
those were slaughtered as well but
that's not really to do with pirate
stuff so I didn't really go too much
into that
now because of Saint Augustine's
location and its geographical attributes
I guess
um it was a very very attractive
um Port not only for legitimate
businessmen if you want to call it that
but also for pirates because the thing
about it is that ships that were going
that were going to cross the Atlantic
would all pretty much come by there you
know what I mean if you were coming
through the Gulf of Mexico with like
your ship Laden with [ __ ] from Central
to South America you had to come all the
way around Florida and you had to come
up there just because of the trade winds
and the you know all that so you had to
come up there uh to go across the
Atlantic to Spain so Pirates started
figuring that out they're like oh my God
like all the ships are coming by here so
it's like a really good location for
them to like station out and the thing
about St Augustine too that's
interesting is there's an island called
Anastasia Island
um and then there's an inlet behind it
and this Inlet was like a good place for
pirates or whoever like they could just
kind of sit in there and wait and they
could see ships passing but the ships
couldn't really see them because the
island was sort of in the way so it was
a really ideal location for like Ambush
Island for like pirate activity and like
I said it still looks like that you can
still if you go to St Augustine today
it's like all kind of pirate [ __ ] and
they'll tell you all the history about
it but uh as I said the Spanish they
weren't dumb so they knew they were kind
of wise to this whole thing so they
actually built watchtowers on Anastasia
Island and ended up posting centuries in
them so you know they'd be able to like
check out was like hey we think there's
maybe Pirates and would send some word
back in case something bad was going on
now one of the first like big pirate
incursions and I know that Sir Francis
Drake isn't usually called a pirate
but he was a privateer
so for everyone other than the English
he was absolutely a pirate you know
uh yeah
now two decades after Saint Augustine
was founded
um which was in 1565 so 1585 from 1586
thereabouts
Sir Francis Drake has a fleet uh of 25
ships and over 2 000 men
now Drake obviously famed sea captain uh
probably one of the most famous in
European history and also a privateer he
was working under the auspices of the
English crown Queen Elizabeth just loved
the dude and she actually sanctioned
Drake's action
um what they would do whatever country
wanted you to be a pirate for them
they would give you this really cool
like official piece of paper that was
all had like all the pretty scroll and
like the wax seals on it and everything
like that I mean the [ __ ] was real
called a letter of Mark yeah
so they'd give you that and that
basically says government says it's
a-okay yeah to go raid as long as you're
raiding like enemy ships yeah like don't
rate any of our [ __ ] right but you know
so at that time the English and the
Spanish were deadly deadly enemies yeah
so obviously Drake they're just like
yeah go [ __ ] the Spanish up and the
thing about it was that this was very
attractive to a lot of
governments uh you know States at the
time because
you were essentially
what they would do is like their say
okay I'll give you a letter of Mark you
can go attack like if it's an English
one you can go attack Spanish treasure
ships and you take X percentage and then
give the rest percentage to the crown
this [ __ ] up the Spanish which is their
enemies and you also get something out
of it and the English win too because
they're like well we're [ __ ] up our
enemy and their supply lines and [ __ ]
like that and we don't really have to
like put a lot of money into like
kidding out a whole entire Navy because
people like individually are doing it
for their own gain yeah you know what I
mean now look don't think this is
something that only happened in antique
Antiquity it happened it's probably
happening now but it was definitely
happening in World War II
Germany had Raiders surface Raiders
where you take a
cargo ship
and you arm it with cannons and then
hide the Cannons underneath things that
would fall away it look it would look
like cargo boxes on the top of it it's
like a David Copperfield magic trick
there it is it's Gus and then they would
[ __ ] is the cannon yeah and then they
would [ __ ] steal surface ships and
raid their and sink them send them to
the bottom or steal their cargo so that
went on even up until World War II it's
probably still going on
you know but uh
under the auspices of [ __ ] whoa we
didn't do it because they would contract
third parties to do it for you you know
so this is probably still going on but
it happened verifiably
up into the 40s
yeah this isn't a [ __ ]
the ways of the sea [ __ ] live on you
know what I mean that's just the way it
is yeah yeah I mean we're mostly talking
about like I said we're not talking
about like yeah it happens in modern day
obviously but we're talking about kind
of like the Golden Age of piracy and
like I said it was absolutely like I
said everybody else if you weren't
English uh yeah everybody else would
consider you a pirate because you're
just like taking over their ship and
you're taking all their [ __ ] right but
he's like hey
uh government says it's okay and it's
like so if he goes back with all the
stuff they're not going to hang him like
they would a pirate they're gonna be
like woohoo thanks for bringing us all
the stuff and you [ __ ] up our enemies
like good for you yeah so very very
common but you needed that letter of
Mark to do it
so if you didn't have that if you did
have that you were Privateer if you
didn't have that you were a pirate
pirate there's no difference but like so
there's really no difference there's
really no difference I mean whether or
not you're a [ __ ] who your clients are
that's all right that's yeah essentially
right yeah so so Drake what he was doing
um he's planning to attack Spanish ports
in the new world he wanted to interrupt
like all the you know kind of shipments
of silver and gold that was going to
King Philip III I believe was the king
at the time or Felipe if you prefer
um and at the same time like I said it
was win-win because England and Spain
were you know at loggerheads at War so
they were kind of like okay well
anything you can do to [ __ ] up the
Spanish that's awesome
so Drake went him and his men they
attacked like Santo Domingo they did
Cartagena
um and then started going back home now
they started they wanted to attack
Havana and Cuba
um but they couldn't really get their
[ __ ] together there so what they decided
to do well we need to like plunder
somewhere else come on where can we go
so he starts sailing North along
Florida's Atlantic Coast looking for
some Spanish own targets because Florida
was owned by the Spanish at that point
so he's like well I need to look for
somewhere that I can [ __ ] up
so in May of 1586
they come up on the Florida like uh the
Atlantic coast and they see a little
fort and an inlet now this turns out to
be Saint Augustine which at the time was
the most northern town in Spain's Empire
in the new world Drake had heard of this
settlement and he was aware that the guy
that ran it uh Admiral Pedro
um he was the guy that had ordered all
the French huguenots massacred
uh that was another thing that pissed
Drake off because you know like I said
the whole England Spain thing was also
like a Protestant Catholic thing so
there was like a lot of religion going
on there as well so Drake is like oh
yeah the guy that oh that runs this
settlement is the same guy that wiped
out all those huguenots hence why that
place is called matanzis so he's like so
this is going to be like a win-win I can
loot the city and I can get revenge on a
dude that wiped out a bunch of
Protestants so he says this is going to
be our next Target
so the English pretty much uh started
attacking what was then like this little
wooden fort and it was just up in the
sand dunes
now there were a few Spanish uh you know
officers or whatever and they were on
duty but they just shot a couple things
and they're just like okay [ __ ] this
this is way above our pay grade so they
[ __ ] took off because it was just
like a whole I mean like I said it was
Drake and he had like a [ __ ] whole
bunch event
so Drake sends in a landing party and
then they rode into the inlet they
didn't see any other Spaniards because
the ones had taken off but they did find
this French Huguenot who had actually
been taken prisoner by the Spanish and
he'd been in you know he'd been held
captive by them for like six years and
was not happy about it so he said tell
you what
um I'll I'll show you like where the
main settlement is so they did find this
guy
now at this point like uh Admiral Pedro
who was the guy that was the governor of
St Augustine at the time
uh he got warned hey Drake is coming in
and he looks at his little Garrison or
whatever there and he's like dude I only
have like a hundred men and they have
like 2 000 men so I'm kind of hosed
so he's like okay what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna go Inland a little bit
and then let them kind of come in and
then when they come and then we'll maybe
do surprise attacks on them later on
because there's like there's no way they
could face them head to head because
they were way outnumbered
so Drake and his guys like come in
around this little fort
um and they seem to like be okay they're
like oh okay well nobody's here we're
just gonna take the [ __ ] but then during
the night
um some allies of the Spanish who were
actually natives of the area like native
like American Indians uh came in and
attacked them
now Drake uh and his guys managed to
like hold their position and uh the
Indians eventually said okay [ __ ] this
it's not worth it and they took off too
now the following day uh Drake and about
200 of his guys come up the inlet and
they soon come across this uh the Ford
of San Juan which at the time was uh
like a stock age is made of logs uh that
was built by the Spanish
now the Spanish did shoot at them uh but
the English landed and basically just
took the fort without too much trouble
because like I said the Spanish were way
outnumbered
now and a lot of them had just run away
because they knew they were outnumbered
and they're like yeah [ __ ] this
now when they came in though they did
find a gun platform that had 14 bronze
artillery pieces on it were like
well here's something we could take they
also found what if we lose connection
we'll try to be up back on as soon as
possible because there's a bunch of
lightning happening outside yeah I mean
yeah we'll see yeah it is storming in
case you can't hear it right but like I
said Florida y'all
uh so yeah so they did find
um
the gun platforms so they were like okay
we can take all that stuff they also
found this big chest which had like the
payroll in it uh about 2 000 gold
duckets not sure how much that is in
today's money but obviously they had
left it behind because they were like in
a hurry so they're like okay we're
having that too
so Drake and the guys took pretty much
everything that was left uh you know the
guns the money everything and then
burned the fort uh to ashes
and after that the English Came Upon the
main settlement of Saint Augustine
because before this this was just the
the little fort that was outside of it
um and they come into the town uh which
was not a huge town at that time it was
just like a little settlement and they
come in and there's nobody there because
like I said the Spanish had retreated to
like uh you know kind of a hiding
position so they could sort of Ambush
them later on
so Drake and the guys like come in there
and uh they're like huh there's nobody
here but then like the Spanish actually
started like firing at them from like
their hidden positions one of the
English officers named Anthony Powell
was killed uh the English men then
charged all the way to the outskirts of
the town uh you know kind of into the
outskirts and then they the Spanish
eventually retreated it's like that they
were outnumbered and Drake was like okay
well I run this [ __ ] now
now the English stayed in the town
overnight and then the following day
they actually like [ __ ] up Saint
Augustine's like burned it to the ground
they burned all the buildings to the
ground they burned all the crops they
just [ __ ] everything up everything
that was worth anything and money guns
anything like that they took it
um if it wasn't worth anything they
destroyed it I mean they just [ __ ]
raised it there was nothing left
um the Florida San Juan was burned and
they just took all the guns and [ __ ]
like that
um so basically the thing about it is
it's interesting is from an American
history standpoint is that Drake was
actually his next stop was going to be
at the Colony of Roanoke so he's like
hey if we find anything here that the
settlers at Roanoke can use pick that up
too and we'll take it to him because
that's the next stop we're gonna make so
that's what he told his guys
um so they actually got like a whole
bunch of the Cannons and [ __ ] like that
uh so as I said they just [ __ ]
torched everything they destroyed
everything and then sailed on to Roanoke
now once the English had taken off uh
Admiral Pedro Admiral Pedro comes out
um and they're like uh they come out and
there's like nothing left St Augustine
is just [ __ ] there's nothing there
everything's just been like burned or
taken or whatever
so he goes to uh the Viceroy of Cuba and
get some money from them like supplies
and stuff and they eventually like build
the settlement back up they replaced uh
the San Juan fort with another wooden
fort and interestingly if you see if you
saw like um I don't remember if I posted
pictures of the fort that's in St
Augustine now which is called Castillo
decent Marcos that wasn't there at the
time that's made of like Coquina it's
masonry then it's made of like Coquina
Rock and stuff like that it's massive
um that wasn't there at the time all the
forts there were wooden
um it was actually another pirate attack
that caused them to build that which
I'll get into in a little bit but see
that wasn't actually built until 1672 so
at this point there was just they kept
putting up wooden ones
so uh yeah so Drake's raid which I think
was just called the raid on St Augustine
it has its own Wikipedia page and
everything because it was like pretty
significant in Florida history and in
American history in general
um that was kind of like it was pretty
significant from a Spanish point of view
because there were like rumors that the
English had a settlement that was like
farther north and were using that
um as like a piracy base at some point
and some Spanish prisoners that had been
captured by the English and released uh
confirmed that they're like yeah he's
going up and like replenishing The
Colony at Roanoke which we did a show
about that like all those [ __ ]
disappeared but yeah so it's an engine
well yeah but I'm just saying that
during this time period Drake when he
did the raid on Saint Augustine he was
actually on his way up to Roanoke and
some of the [ __ ] that he stole from
Saint Augustine he was taking up there
to them to like to the settlers so I
thought that was like kind of
interesting
um but yeah
so
there's there was a thing afterward like
after that whole thing happened like
admirable Admiral why do I want to say
admirable I keep wanting to say
admirable instead of Adam it's just it's
just like I just want to add that extra
syllable I don't know why that's so
attractive to me but my mouth is not
like behaving and I'm not even it's like
I haven't even started my second drink
so I don't even know I'm not that drunk
but yeah so Admiral Pedro maybe I'll
just call him Pedro that I don't have to
worry about it anymore what's up Pedro
he's dead he doesn't care
um so yeah so he basically like goes to
the king and everything like that he's
like you know I think because they the
Spanish also had some uh settlements
like in South Carolina and stuff he's
like I think that we should kind of
concentrate everything in one place and
that place should be Saint Augustine and
so he kind of like argued about it and
then finally they they kind of like
argued with him a little bit but then
they were like okay fine so he kind of
like put everything down there they
rebuilt it it was fine
now Saint Augustine was also attacked by
another notable Buccaneer not a
privateer this time an actual pirate uh
by the name of Robert Searle sometimes
Searles I've seen it both like with an S
at the end
um you know it's one of those things
where back in the old days they didn't
have like names I guess or like names
they were like nor they were like
normalized in spelling or whatever uh so
as I mentioned earlier the spelling was
normalized that's what I'm saying it's
just kind of like they were just like
whatever whatever we feel like on the
day today I feel like putting an s on
the end yeah today I feel like spelling
it this way yeah yeah that's the thing
like the and I don't I'm sure other
languages are the same but English in
particular uh they didn't standardize
the spelling until quite recently yeah
like 1800s yeah I think it was the 1800s
like before that it's like they kind of
had a few
you know as long as you as long as you
got your point across it was phonetic
yeah basically but they didn't really
have standardized spellings or anything
like that really
but as I mentioned earlier the term
Buccaneer uh which was generally it was
just like a general term that meant any
of the pirates that operated in the
Caribbean uh specifically during the
golden golden age of piracy uh the term
Buccaneer as I mentioned comes from the
Arawak word uh bucan which is the the
thing that they you know that they
smoked the meat on
um you know so the French colonists uh
started calling it uh Buccaneer I guess
uh referring to uh the people who you
know on Hispaniola which is now uh
that's now Haiti right or the Dominican
Republic yes
um and Tortuga and those guys like
attack Spanish ships when they came by
so the the term became
interchangeable with like pirate because
you know hey those guys smoke meat and
then they also attack ships when they
come by so the foods you see smoking
meat it's a pirate it's them yeah those
are the ones that are I mean that's
basically where the word came from
because they Associated the guys that
smoked meat the Europeans that smoked
meat yeah with the Europeans that also
attacked treasure ships that were coming
through there so it was like a pirate
word yeah I think they were mostly
spoken fish
or whatever I guess whatever me it looks
like I said I said the Arawak Indians
were probably smoking other kinds of
measles probably like yeah anyone on the
beach which makes me think that they
were netting probably it was probably
fish yeah
so yeah so this we're jumping ahead like
a century because this is about a
hundred years but I think it's more like
80 years and it was like 80 years
after Drake attacked Saint Augustine uh
you have the other pirate Robert Searle
who sometimes uh use the Alias John
Davis now his home base was Jamaica
now they don't really know too much
about his early life much like most
pirates uh you didn't really hear about
them unless they got caught or unless uh
you know they attacked a ship and it was
in like the Navy logs or something like
that you know what I mean so they didn't
really know like what these people were
doing when they were younger uh the
first mention of him in the historical
record is actually there was a
expedition in Cuba that he was like a
part of
so in 1668 uh Cyril and his men they
were sailing off the coast of Cuba and
they captured a Spanish frigate uh which
was bound for Veracruz and another ship
that was on the way to Havana Cuba
now on board this particular ship was a
French surgeon uh the first ship
actually the the one that was going to
Veracruz there was a French surgeon and
his name was Pedro pickez pickez I think
is how you pronounce that
now this guy
um they're not entirely sure they think
he got punished by a good old Admiral
Pedro
and they're not sure if it's because he
was kind of like a narc and he had like
told some Pirates like about the
location of Saint Augustine or kind of
clued them into like where the [ __ ] was
but he pretty much exiled him from Saint
Augustine so he was on this particular
ship like when the Pirates took it
so
uh Cyril he was like
um okay well this guy they think this
guy's here and he knows a lot about
Saint Augustine because he used to live
there so we're gonna make that our next
Target of attack so they don't know if
he told him some [ __ ] about the city he
probably did but that's probably why
they decided they were going to attack
that City next uh and they think too
that he might have told them that the
treasury of Saint Augustine had a whole
bunch of like silver bars in there which
they had got from his shipwreck so Cyril
uh he had
another he had his ship and then he had
another pirate ship but then like the
two Spanish ships that he captured he
took those as well and he's like ooh I
can use these for subterfuge purposes
so what they did was they sailed up
towards Saint Augustine now the two
pirate ships kind of kept on the DL
right but the other two ships they let
those kind of go out ahead because those
were like legit looking ships right so
they're doing like a whole little yeah
like I said they're doing a whole little
[ __ ] Trojan Horse kind of situation
so may 1668
the two legitimate looking ships come
within hailing distance of the fort in
Saint Augustine
and uh so the Pirates are like hiding
out
now the pile of the harbor pilot comes
out like he normally would and he's like
well where are these ships from what do
you got on there like what's going on
and he's like oh yeah we're from Mexico
and we have a bunch of supplies that
we're supposed to bring here
so the harbor Pilot's like Okay sounds
legit
um and the Pilot's men what they did was
they had a signal where they'd fire two
shots in the air like hey everything's
okay you know don't don't start shooting
at people and uh so yeah
so everybody's like okay cool it's two
ships that have come in like bringing us
stuff now the pilot and his men get on
board these two Spanish vessels that the
Pirates had stolen
now for whatever reason the pilot in
this situation would normally bring the
ships into the harbor but they don't
really know why but they stayed out
where they were like anchored out where
they had you know where they had dropped
their anchors they just left them out
there uh nobody seemed suspicious nobody
thought that there was like pirates in
the wings or anything like that so like
oh everything's fine so everybody just
the day went on and everybody just went
to bed like normal
around uh middle of the night
but it got dark
Cyril and his men the other Pirates they
took their little pirate ships and went
around the guns and into the harbor
and uh they would have snuck in without
completely being seen
if one [ __ ] hadn't been out
there fishing
he was there was a guy named Corporal
Miguel de manzon
yeah and he was out fishing in the
middle of the [ __ ] night like a
weirdo yeah and he saw the [ __ ]
Pirates good at night I know fish is
good he was the only [ __ ] that
was out there everybody else was asleep
the Pirates are probably like God damn
it one dude one dude yeah he trying to
catch the fish he was just out there so
so yeah so the guy saw him uh he
actually heard them first he heard like
the oars and he was just like what the
[ __ ] is that they're not supposed to be
here uh so he's like so he starts
paddling real quick like he was in a
little boat like toward the land right
um so the Pirates chased him and they
shot at him and uh they did hit him like
they didn't kill him or nothing like
that but they wounded him right but he
actually like got like a g he got like
off the boat and he ran to the Garrison
and woke everybody up said [ __ ]
pirates pirates
so uh it didn't really help him though
gotta say because the Pirates were
already there and everybody was just
like waking up people what Pirates it
must have been like that uh so they
didn't really have a lot you know they
didn't really have a whole lot of
warning they're all in their jammies and
whatnot so most of them got killed uh or
captured because the Pirates pretty much
just came right on land and just [ __ ]
went ham they just went all over the
[ __ ] place swarming the place uh went
through all the government buildings the
church everything they just took
everything
uh and if they couldn't take it then
they destroyed it they burned it
uh now the Pirates ended up losing 11
men
in the raid uh 19 were injured now the
people that were living in Saint
Augustine at the time
uh some of them did survive because they
ran to the Fort which actually didn't
fall or they ran out into the forest uh
but about a quarter of the population of
the town at the time which was about 60
Spaniards uh died in the attack now the
Pirates
uh Cyril and the Pirates did take 70
uh children and adults as hostages
and these he later exchanged for various
Provisions including firewood and other
things
uh he didn't free any of the uh blacks
or Indians that he took
um he's like
his letter he had a letter of that's the
thing I guess he technically is a
privateer because he had a letter of
Mark
from the governor of Jamaica but see
most European crowns would not honor
that if they'd be like what that's not a
[ __ ] that's not a real country yeah yeah
so yeah yeah but he did technically have
a thing and he said that his letter of
Mark
um hey I'm allowed to sell anybody
that's not a Spaniard right so he's like
I'm Gonna Keep all these [ __ ]
right so don't get as Democratic as the
Pirates might have been in some ways
they absolutely would sell your ass into
sleep oh yeah they did they voted on it
definitely they voted on that yeah yeah
so don't get I mean and I'm not saying
because the thing about it there were um
there were a lot of black Pirates a lot
because a lot of them were freed slaves
and they're like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] too yeah well that's what
I'm saying they would they would pretty
much do anything that made them but
anything that was a commodity yeah then
they would sell it right I mean it
wasn't racial no they didn't really
people [ __ ] would sell white people
black people would sell white people
well and some of the people that went
into piracy too and some of the people
that were sold into slavery were
indentured servants and a lot of those
were uh particularly a little bit later
were Irish yeah because a lot of people
would like well a lot of Irish would
sell themselves into indention yeah
servitude for like seven years or
something like they were Irish slaves
there were there was so yeah people do
not understand history okay [ __ ]
these modern [ __ ] going to
these universities they're not telling
the story straight
slavery didn't have a whole lot to do
with race it had to do with whether or
not you were vulnerable okay if you were
in an area that did not have a
nation-state protecting you and your
interests you could be [ __ ]
shanghaied or [ __ ] or captured and
sold as a slave it didn't matter [ __ ]
what color you were it was just that no
one no one protected you you weren't
part of a Nation
and uh it [ __ ]
and even if even if you were in a
[ __ ] nation state you could still get
Shanghai
people didn't follow rules
uh we sometimes were like well what the
[ __ ] is shanghaied mean
there was a phenomenon that would happen
usually if you were a white sailor
you could be in a bar somewhere
drinking
and then
wake up and be in a [ __ ] ship's hole
yeah you'd be honest in China yeah
you're like where the [ __ ] am I doing
here you've been Shanghai you're going
to Shanghai okay you're gonna [ __ ]
serve on this ship you know and you're
you're being sold as a slave
now would you get out of it
yeah you probably would but it would
take years
yeah
world was a dangerous place
yeah it's like I would not when it was
like the world back then man yeah
I mean at least now most people at least
in the western world like have some
concept of like a little bit of control
over your own life and [ __ ] like that I
mean you're not gonna be drinking in a
bar and somebody's like gonna I mean
probably 99 of the time yeah Someone's
Not Gonna kidnap you and like hey you're
in the Navy now you're in the Navy now
you're gonna be good we're gonna take
you to a country you've never been to if
you haven't made it yet you work here
now we're gonna put you in indentured
servitude yeah I mean that very very
rarely happens I'm sure it happens in
other parts of the world still but it
doesn't usually happen here one of the
reasons why it doesn't happen as much as
it did is because we don't live in a
world where the economy is labor driven
we have an excess of people so you you
don't really need people like you used
to they've been replaced by robotics
so you don't have to Shanghai people
like well now people get Shanghai for
like [ __ ] different sex sex you're
right like trash trade is the is how you
get saying [ __ ] it's saying that
Shanghai because that absolutely does
happen yeah in the United States yeah
you cannot replace you cannot replace
that [ __ ] with a robot yet okay but
eventually they will and then even even
a human woman won't be worth anything
once the second in a way that's kind of
good though because I'm like well
that could be fun at least people well I
don't know it's I'm sure it'll have
downsides but yeah I'm like if they're
not like kidnapping look it's like if
you're some weirder that's in like some
freaky [ __ ] and there's like an AI like
cyborg that is close enough to real
thing that you don't have to like kidnap
a real person yeah to do that then good
yeah there's always going to be
fetishists that happen to have a [ __ ]
real woman okay
I think it'll be
fetish it'll be like a lot less like
prevalent
uh [ __ ] from what I've been hearing
lately AI is good enough
for a sex bot
and uh yeah I mean it's for most people
I'm sure it probably is at this stage
and they can make those bodies it's only
a matter of time before they start
selling those things
who knows what that will do to the
reproductive cycle because a lot of
these [ __ ] a lot of these
incels get married so they can have sex
and that's where people come from
but the thing about it though is that in
cells Yeah by their definition don't get
laid I just I use that as a
generalization they don't kill it
so it's like and look if if we can give
incels sex bots so they'll shut up and
leave the rest of us alone and like stop
shooting up places and whatnot like
their want to do then good that's a win
you just have that sex bot and just stay
over there away from normal people how
about that you know what I'm saying you
know I I think it's a win I think it's a
win for Humanity as a whole I'm not
saying that it doesn't have like some
downsides everything does but I think in
general it will probably be it will
probably be a win
so yeah so Cyril and the other Pirates
um like I said they they kept a lot of
the people because they're like hey we
can sell these as slaves don't like take
these away they also got away here's
what they got away with 133 silver marks
I don't think that was a huge amount of
money but that was what they had
um a whole bunch of canvas that they
could use to like make sales with a
whole bunch of candles which doesn't
sound like much but it was probably like
a big deal back then like before
electricity like woo candles
um they got like all the stuff from the
church they had a whole bunch of like
jewels and just just silver and regular
[ __ ] like that
so they hung out in the city for about
uh for about a day 20 hours something
like that and then they took off now
what ended up happening his attack on
Saint Augustine was again a really big
deal this was like the second big Pirate
Invasion in within a century uh as I
said Sir Francis Drake's one it was
destroyed I mean there was nothing left
to the place and they had like rebuilt
it over the subsequent 80 90 years and
here comes this [ __ ] and like
[ __ ] it all up again
um so basically they took most of the
food supplies
um for the people that were living there
uh they took uh all the ships pretty
much
um that you know the residents of the
town like needed
so basically it was kind of like
there was something too that and this is
kind of like leading up to why the
Coquina Fort that's still there today uh
was built was that a lot of people in
the town they thought they saw like some
of the captives and [ __ ] like that
thought they had seen some of the
Pirates taking soundings in the harbor
and they said oh well they're planning
another attack they're gonna come back
later on and take like all the [ __ ] they
didn't take this time or you know
they're planning to take about when when
they build it up again so
you know and it was also kind of
suspicious that the Pirates hadn't
burned the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] down like
Drake did so they're like they're gonna
come back like later on after we build
up a little bit because it's such a
vulnerable area I mean it's it's a it's
a very
um tempting Target I guess like Saint
Augustine was at the time
so because of that because they
suspected that there were going to be
more pirate attacks
um they figured well we need like a way
bigger more impenetrable Fort so four
years after uh searle's attack they
started building
um Castillo de San Marcos which is still
there today is a massive massive uh
masonry Fort made of Coquina and uh
still standing there to this day and uh
as far as I know after they built that
Fort Pirates are just kind of like no
too much trouble because if you see the
place you'll know why it's like a
massive massive structure and it's just
like and honestly there's never
even nowadays you can go there and see
it
and they're still kind of like
cannonballs like embedded in the walls
like because they shoot a cannon at it
it would just go dunk and it would just
stick in the wall it would just stay
there so they couldn't really like get
through it it's just like really really
thick like Coquina walls so it's pretty
much impenetrable and once they built
that uh the Pirates didn't really [ __ ]
with them too much anymore
now uh so over the years as I mentioned
Florida it's a really big if you go
anywhere like St Augustine or any kind
of or Tampa or anywhere like that and
you go in a gift shop they're gonna try
and sell you like some [ __ ] treasure
maps man because
the Atlantic Ocean and the Gulf of
Mexico
are littered with Rex
uh and that's not that's not imagination
they found like a bunch of pirate wrecks
they've found like a bunch and there's a
bunch that they haven't found too
because you have to think Not only was
this a major major uh shipping Lane
for all of the treasure uh galleons that
were going from Central South America
back to Spain uh also it's Florida and
we have hurricanes so pretty much when
they were sailing in the summertime
that's like Prime hurricane season and a
lot a lot a lot of ships and sometimes
like a whole Battalion of ships would go
down in a hurricane and sometimes they
haven't been found so Florida has kind
of like a little bit of a
I mean you have like somebody mentioned
Mel Fisher earlier
um they have like a whole kind of like
little subculture of treasure Hunters
like people that go out on boats and
like try to find and there's still like
tons of [ __ ] out there to find and I'm
not saying there's not because there's a
bunch of it uh so the biggest disaster
is probably like the fleet of 1622
there was a big one in 1715 there was a
big one in 1733. in 1622 actually there
were eight ships and they were coming
into the Florida Straits and they were
lost in a hurricane so that's like eight
ships at the bottom of the thing
um they found uh some of these lost
ships as I mentioned uh the nuestro
Senora the Atocha from the 1622 Fleet
they found that
uh the erka De Lima from the 1715 Fleet
and the San Pedro from the 1733 Fleet so
they have found some of the ships but so
many of them went down and they've been
like scattered uh over the ocean floor
and or the Gulf War since then so
there's still like a bunch of [ __ ] out
there to be found which like I said
that's why there's a lot of [ __ ]
treasure Hunters so the 1715 one
um it was July of 1715 and there were 11
vessels I think there were 12 and one
got away but 11 vessels from this what
they call the 1715 treasure Fleet uh
they were heading out from Havana and
they actually it was a hurricane again
and it wrecked uh near Cape Canaveral
which is on the East Coast on Cape
Canaveral obviously that's where the um
all the space shuttles go off from and
that's about that's probably about
50 60 miles south from where I grew up
because I grew up in Daytona Beach
and we used to drive down to Cape
Canaveral to see the shuttles go off and
it was about an hour hour and 15 minute
drive I think it's about 50 miles if I'm
not mistaken this is about 50 miles
south of where I grew up
um now interestingly because this
particular uh event
all the ships going down
uh in 1715 in the hurricane
the distress call uh got to Jamaica in
November of 1715 and there was another
pirate there whose little ears perked
right up hey with all those [ __ ]
ships that just went down I'm gonna go
check that out his name was Henry
Jennings also a pirate also I think he
kinda also had the in premature of the
English crown so I guess technically a
privateer but like I said same kind of
thing now he had a ship called the
bersheba
so he heard about all these Spanish
ships going down and goes cha-ching and
starts sailing out for the Florida coast
now he also had a um he had that letter
of Mark II from the Jamaican government
the
his letter said that he was able to and
this is a quote execute all manner of
Acts of hostility against Pirates
according to the law of arms with
explicit instructions not to attack
anyone except Pirates which seems like a
pretty vague
thing to like say you know what I'm
saying Jack anyone except virus yeah no
it you can attack anybody only Pirates
yeah you can attack only Pirates it's
like but hey they look like Pirates to
me okay
they had parrots on their shoulders and
their wooden legs and everything so I
just I thought they were pirates I don't
know so he could probably like get away
with it you could probably you could
probably recognize him back then
yeah like I said I was reading that book
under the Black Flag and he was talking
about like the way that pirates are
dressed like in movies and stuff yeah
and he's like that's actually fairly
accurate
he's like even the captains with like
the the big wigs and like the hats and
the crazy like they're like that's not
too far off because some of them were
pretty Pimpin because they would steal
like a bunch of expensive [ __ ] like
silks and everything like that from
other ships and be like oh this is nice
I'm gonna wear this [ __ ] so they do
there are some like trial records of
pirates that got caught and like the
Pirates would come to trial and they'd
be like [ __ ] they'd be looking all
fly yeah yeah so some of them not all of
them obviously but your Pirates like on
the regular ships yeah they've just
basically were yeah they did wear those
things on their heads like you know
handkerchief type stuff on their heads
they all had all they were all like tons
and tons of pistols and cutlasses and
stuff like that like around their belt
but and they would wear like the
breeches
so yeah they're like that's pretty
accurate okay let me say something about
pistols
back in the day
in this era the quintessential pistol
was the match lock
it should be Flintlock really match
locks were a little expensive but the
flintlock
and it was a mechanical percussion
pistol with a flint and a frizzen pan
and all that
but the reloading time was a lot long
took it took a long time to reload that
the average pirate carried six six
pistols at least
they did they had a bunch they had a
bunch of them because you there was no
time to reload well and plus if you were
at Sea like your [ __ ] might get wet and
so you didn't know like some of the [ __ ]
was like not gonna they had them all
into belts and they were all tied
together on lanyards okay
so I'm just
which made sense
you wanted them tied together you just
dropped one and go to a next one you
didn't have to worry about re-holstering
so towards the end of a [ __ ]
combat run he'd have a bunch of pistols
swinging
on the end of [ __ ] little lanyards
you know ropes yeah they had like ropes
that they kept them on they have found
those like in yeah in Rex and stuff
right yo so uh at Sea you want
everything in in general to be tied to
you
can't fall overboard yeah it makes sense
right because you wouldn't want to be
like hey I'm going to shoot you oh [ __ ]
yeah
well you're boarding you're jumping from
one one chip to the next and you don't
want to drop anything and then it goes
into the sea so it's got to be tied to
you
and uh you also like I said you don't
want to re-holster or rebuild something
you just boom you should just drop it go
for the next one it's like I'll get that
you're hanging and Swinging banging on
your knees and [ __ ]
but that's just the way it was we kind
of did the same thing in the army with
magazines so you're like what yeah we
had to [ __ ] keep all our M16
magazines you had to keep track of them
we had them all taped and tied on the
bottom and then the [ __ ] 550 cord
that went to the bottom of your magazine
pouch so when you dumped a [ __ ] M16
mag you just threw it and it would just
be hanging on a line and you grab
another one
because you don't care that that shit's
[ __ ] banging around you're crawling
and stuff you know after the action
after combat you'd put all that [ __ ]
back together
but it's not like it is in the movies
it's not as glamorous this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] nothing's ever as glamorous as
it looks in the movies it's easy for
like [ __ ] to look glamorous in the
movies right yeah it's like we're only
filming like five minutes after we spent
like five hours getting setting all this
[ __ ] up yeah
because them the Army's ability to
reissue you a [ __ ] magazine is
no they might be able to reissue you
[ __ ] ammo but not magazines so
[ __ ] you're gonna tie that to you and
it's going to be [ __ ]
550 cord going down to the bottom of
your [ __ ] magazine pouch yeah they
had like it's uh yeah I was reading
something about that just uh last night
where it's like yeah they had like
slings everything was like tied to them
with like slings
yeah and that's
they learned to do that
all armies learn to do that by
experience
it's not something you learn out of a
book
you have to protect the [ __ ] that you
have because there won't be a
replacement
you know yeah it's not like not a pinch
you can go to the Walgreens right
Camp guy said they still finding gold
coins on the beach at Sebastian Inlet
yeah that's right actually all of those
kind of like those Island inlets and
stuff like that there's all they're
always finding like [ __ ] there
and they also said they're still looking
for about half of the Atocha stuff yeah
they are uh one of the most famous oh
this is funny because I just saw a
documentary about this earlier today one
of the most famous treasure finds in
history was but a first time 17 year old
kid that found a 12 foot long gold chain
and a two and a half inch Chinese gold
toothpick charm he just found out of
sand yeah that's right I saw I saw that
I was watching a documentary today about
piracy and they showed that it's like
this big and I was like who the [ __ ]
rich people have entirely too much money
obviously because back in the day it's
like hey I want this big [ __ ]
ass this big pimping ass Flavor Flav
chain with it has like this what I
couldn't figure out like it's some kind
of animal was it some kind of animal
like I couldn't figure out what it was
but it was like and they said it was
like a toothpick it's like a gold
toothpick on this big [ __ ] gold chain
teeth you don't know yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm like all right
well they probably didn't have
toothbrush well I know that but
man they probably did that at the dinner
table too yeah uncouth [ __ ]
trying to pull that plaque off her teeth
excuse me
[Laughter]
I don't know but yeah I saw that I saw
what you're talking about I couldn't
figure yeah it was like some kind of it
looked like a I don't know it looked
like a panther I don't know what it
remember like what it looked like but
yeah it was something badass I guess
yeah but it's a toothpick yeah because
probably like if you saw you'd be like
ooh badass it's like a spike and they're
like yeah they just used it like
oh my god oh it's a fish okay I couldn't
tell exactly it was a fish well I was
just kind of like looking at because I
was writing something over here and like
kind of watching it with like half my
attention you probably would have begged
together that's not a fish it's a whale
or so [ __ ] like that it's a shark it's a
shark yeah it's something badass well
like you said if it's just something
like yeah it's like some five-year-old
boy [ __ ] I want a toothpick that looks
like a shark yeah
but made of solid gold with a big solid
gold chain so I can hang it around my
neck and pick my teeth at the dinner
table all of old-fashioned history is
like it was written by 15 year old boys
it's true it is I mean yeah
especially having to do with the new
world it's like children wrote it
yeah yeah well they were kind of
children I mean they didn't live long
they didn't live long yeah they didn't
really have a chance so it was all fun
you get old and like reflect on there
man I was stupid back then yeah
oh my God so so yeah where was I okay so
Henry Jennings like I said he hears
about all of these ships going down in a
hurricane
with all this stuff on it and he's like
hey I'm gonna go check that out so he
gets to Florida in early 1716. now by
the time he got there
um now the Spanish weren't slouches I
mean sometimes when their ships went
down in hurricanes they did actually
have recovery Crews like they had diving
bells and [ __ ] like that like they could
go recover some of it you know what I
mean so by the time that the pirate uh
Henry Jennings got there most of the
treasure had been recovered uh by the
Spanish and they took it back to Havana
so uh what Jennings did though this is
this is easy piracy
but he found out that some of the stuff
that they had recovered they had had it
all packed up and they were gonna like
send it uh you know to wherever it
needed to go
but it was just in this fort that didn't
really have that many guards uh at this
place called Palma de eyes which they
think is maybe close to modern day Vero
Beach
and so he's like well [ __ ] it's just
sitting here like nobody I'm just gonna
take it so that's pretty much like like
I said easy piracy you didn't have to
like take a [ __ ] for nothing it was just
sitting there so he's like well I'm
gonna take that [ __ ] so technically that
was his first Act of piracy was just
taking stuff that was laying there like
that was very lightly guarded
so uh he actually had three ships at
this point and about 300 dudes so they
basically ambushed the camp and took all
the [ __ ]
um I think there was like 60 dudes there
but like I said he had 300 dudes so
they're like you know the guys got
overwhelmed so they got away with what
they estimate to be about 87
000 pounds in gold and silver uh which
was the equivalent to about a 10-year
salary back then so not too bad a haul
for just like laying there on a [ __ ]
beach and you didn't even really have to
do much of anything to get it
so they went back to Jamaica with their
spoil shortly after
and he continued doing pirating nowhere
else in Florida though as far as I know
um now interestingly Jennings is one of
the few pirates that actually they think
retired in semi-luxury most of them were
killed they were either executed or they
died violently or something like that
it's not a real sustainable lifestyle no
Henry Jennings though uh was a little
bit of an exception he did keep pirating
like after this whole this First Act of
piracy here where she just stole some
[ __ ] from the Spanish galleons that they
had recovered but there was in 1718 I
thought this was very interesting
in the Bahamas
there was actually an amnesty for
pirates
they basically like the governor of the
Bahamas came out and said if you're a
pirate and you
um admit you're a pirate yeah and like
surrender and you stop all the pirating
within the next year then you'll get a
pardon yeah
so Henry Jennings said sign me up so he
went over there and did it yeah he's
like yeah man I'm a pirate yeah cause
he'd been play pirating for like years
and years so he did it yeah and he had a
[ __ ] ton of money and they said he ended
up living in Bermuda as a very wealthy
he had a big Plantation there so he's
very well respected retirement plan yeah
plan yeah he did it good he said he was
like the only guy one of the only famous
pirates that actually like retired
instead of like getting killed or
executed yeah yeah I mean they don't
actually know I mean yeah he did come in
he did get amnesty so he didn't get
hanged or anything like that in general
people most pirates were hanged most of
them yeah that's how most of them died
arrested and hanged by some kind of an
enemy
yeah that's how they went and I mean I
said life expectancy was three or four
years and I kind of feel like too during
the Golden Age of piracy I kind of feel
like because there were so many
privateers they weren't as hard on
Pirates I kind of feel like after
after the need for piracy wasn't as
maybe wasn't as prevalent because there
were other sources of income from other
like governments I feel like a lot of
governments and royal families have like
turned against piracy and then started
cracking down on it yeah and that's when
you kind of saw a lot of
because piracy really kind of like
declined after about 17 30 or there but
a lot of the pirate stories have to do
with what happened after capture
yeah it's like there's I remember
reading a lot of stories
them being being in some prison in
Jamaica
and [ __ ] con there are Court hearings
and them talking to each other out on
the courtyard we're gonna hang this time
aren't we yeah yeah we're gonna [ __ ]
they're gonna kill us [ __ ] and that
that really is what happened to most of
them [ __ ] hand yeah
so yeah well that's why Henry Jennings
is kind of an exception because they're
like he's but I mean they don't know
what they don't know when and where he
died so it's possible that he retired
wealthy for a little while and then said
I miss pirating and then like went back
and then got arrested for some other
stupid just like [ __ ] Blackbeard or
Edward Teach or thatch whatever his name
was they're not really sure what his
name was he could have retired there
were several there were several
instances where he could have given it
up I mean he married the [ __ ]
daughter of [ __ ] one of the governors
and he was a celebrity and he could have
just stopped stopped the lifestyle and
getting it up what does he do she makes
fun of his socks so he's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] and [ __ ] gifts her over to
the crew for a mass raping and then goes
back to being a [ __ ] pirate and then
and then just because of his socks yeah
making fun of his socks men's egos are
so fragile well he had holes in his
socks he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
[ __ ] he he started he shared the
booty that's where that comes from I
mean I can't imagine yeah
yeah I can't imagine
anything that you could do well I don't
know about that anything that you can do
that make me mad enough
to like just say hey here how about it
like
throw someone out for gang rape
I would really have to hate you I mean
you would have to be like basically
Hitler for me to do something like that
you just like made fun of my socks I'd
be like
I like my socks
so
I would not get upset at all I don't
understand I don't understand these
dates are just like they're socks man
why are you so upset about it I don't
understand like I said [ __ ] dudes are
so fragile they're so fragile they're
little egos but yeah so it sucks had
holes in it and he's like yeah Mass
raping for you okay but yeah [ __ ]
Blackbeard
speaking of Blackbeard
now we're going to talk about another
pirate this is a not Blackbeard but one
that's kind of sort of the tangentially
associated with black Blackbeard but
we're going to talk about another famous
pirate associated with Florida and I'm
gonna wait till Tom gets back because
he'll probably want to hear this story
but yeah oh but what I was going to say
about Henry Jennings is that
even though they do know that he for a
time was like a wealthy Plantation owner
in Bermuda and uh you know was very well
respected in the city they don't
ultimately know what happened to him so
they like it's possible that he maybe
got in trouble later on and died in a
prison somewhere or maybe he had a
family and lived out his life like
normal but if he did like I said he
would be one of the very very few
Pirates to have done that because most
of them were executed or died at Sea you
know died in battles that's basically
what you signed up for when you decided
to go pirating uh so yeah well he's
taking forever so I'm just gonna go
ahead and talk about this all right so
another famous pirate associated with
Florida
and I feel like this is one he's a guy
that doesn't get brought up a lot uh
this guy's named Black Caesar uh or
Henry Caesar I've seen him called that
as well although I think there's
confusion because I think there's two
different ones that were called Caesar
and I'm not sure if they're all talking
about the same guy or if it's like two
different guys like one guy taking the
name of the other guy you know what I
mean but anyway so Black Caesar he's
kind of like a guy that operated during
the Golden Age of piracy from you know
1600s to about 1730 or so
now they know for sure there's a lot of
stuff about him that's sort of like
legendary they're not really sure if
it's true or not like he was a real guy
they know that because they know for
sure that he was uh did actually serve
aboard the ship of Blackbeard Edward
Teach uh which was called the Queen
Anne's Revenge and he was actually
um one of the guys that survived like uh
during the career when Blackbeard died
uh in 1718 Black Caesar was one of his
crew members that uh lived through that
so he actually served on that ship for a
while what are you doing I forgot he's
just like he's watering all over the
[ __ ] house
what is poop where's Pookie in the in
the bowl
uh so yeah they do know that he served
on the ship with Blackbeard that he was
part of Blackbeard's crew on the Queen
Anne's Revenge and that he was there
when Blackbeard was killed in 1718.
however
there are a bunch of like uh myths about
his life
um kind of that have kind of become
intermingled with like real facts about
his life like I said I'm pretty sure he
was a real guy but it's kind of hard to
like separate myth from fact at this
point
um they think that maybe he kind of like
terrorized the Florida Keys that he was
originally African royalty things like
that
um but nobody knows like how much of
that who Black Caesar Black Caesar yeah
he was African-American we were African
wouldn't he yeah yes I thought yeah I
always heard
the story I heard
not so much he was African bro well
maybe he was African royalty but I think
that he was a slave in Haiti and escaped
during a Revolt yeah and then became a
pirate that was the story I always heard
yeah I remember that guy yeah I mean
he's very very associated with Florida
that guy particularly the Florida Keys
like I said back in the old world
didn't have much to do with your with
your race it had to do whether or not
you could deliver okay [ __ ] in your
head people of all different kinds of
[ __ ] races and ethnic groups if they
could deliver they could put food on the
table and they could lead men then
[ __ ] they got it done all right now
the Imperials wouldn't have [ __ ] ever
approved of that but
in a way this is a weird thing man some
people might be like oh well that's
[ __ ] crazy
the Pirates were kind of in a way very
very North American they were very
[ __ ] American in a way
they were mostly over here and they had
a lot of the same value systems that
ended up being in America
and during the Revolutionary period
Pirates
helped the creation of the of the United
States
Pirates were very much a thing of
[ __ ] of uh uh uh they were kind of
masonic
and the Masonic orders were very kind of
like anti-imperial
they weren't they were more into like uh
could you [ __ ] spin a good narrative
could was it democratically elected did
everybody agree on this
is
it
is it rational you know and that's
really what the Pirates are about the
Pirates were actually rational as virus
as violent as they were they're
practical because practicality and
rationality are very similar
so what Rose to the top rows to the top
there's no denying it
so all right so you know what I'm
talking about huh you know what I'm
talking about though right yeah yeah
okay
why'd you always say that
I'm just trying to get on with the story
and get on with it
all right
so according to most of the stories
Black Caesar uh started out as a
chieftain in Africa
um known for being a real big dude uh
and a very very intelligent dude and uh
very very strong now a lot of slave
Traders had apparently tried to capture
him but had failed but he finally did
get captured when him and 20 of his guys
like his warriors were lured onto the
ship by a slave trader like ooh look at
all this nice stuff we have to come and
see our Wares blah blah blah and so they
get on the ship and uh unbeknownst to
them like the guys are like okay we're
gonna put the ship out now like while
they're looking at the stuff yeah they
did that kind of play yeah so like I
said I don't know if this is how the
story goes
so uh obviously when they found out the
ship was actually like uh you know at
sale like on the ocean and stuff and
they were on the ship they were not
happy about it Black Caesar and his men
yeah so they attempted to fight back but
because they were outnumbered
um and they didn't really have their
weapons with them they were uh you know
laid down pretty quickly
so they didn't like it so they just kind
of like sat there or you know while they
were going across the Atlantic now
apparently Black Caesar would only
befriended this one dude uh I don't know
what his name was but it was a sailor on
this ship and he was the only guy that
could like give water and food to Black
Caesar he was like anybody else tried to
do it he'd be like [ __ ] y'all I don't
want anything to do with you this is
this but one guy a good movie but one
guy yeah they made a movie about Black
Caesar yeah like I said he's kind of
like a well-known pirate like in Florida
lore but I don't know how well known he
is like in just general American history
yeah
now so they're on the ship and they're
coming up to Florida and uh as usually
happens in Florida a [ __ ] hurricane
comes up because we're just like lousy
with the things yeah
so the hurricane comes in they didn't
have like [ __ ] weather watch back
then so it's like you didn't know the
hurricane was coming you'd just be like
in the Atlantic and be like oh [ __ ] me
look at this you know what I mean it
wasn't like you knew a week ahead of
time when the show was coming yeah just
hit you yeah it was just like it snuck
up on you
so uh so yeah the Hurricane's coming
it's gonna like [ __ ] the ships the ship
up
so uh the Sailor at this point is like
okay well we're probably hosed
the sailor who was friends with Black
Caesar he's like we're probably hosed uh
so I'm gonna go down and I'm gonna
release you guys so at least you guys
have a chance right so he went in there
and like uh let
Black Caesar and his men go
and at that point
um basically Black Caesar and the Sailor
I guess they came up and they basically
like
they took over the ship they took over
the ship
um so they're like and then they got
onto one of the long boats uh with a
bunch of [ __ ] from the ship like
ammunition and whatnot and then they
safely made it to the shore now
apparently the ship that they came from
got [ __ ] up in the hurricane just like
they thought so and there were probably
the likely no survivors so everybody
that got off in the Long Boat they were
the only people that survived from that
ship
so what they would do immediately they
started doing pirate [ __ ] okay so
they're on this Lifeboat and they're
like um okay what we're gonna do is
we're gonna pretend that well I mean
they're not pretending they're like we
are actually like just in this boat and
they're from you know in a storm or
whatever so it's like hey we need help
and then like when a ship would come
over to help them then they would get on
there and take their [ __ ]
well yeah that's that's even in the
movie the [ __ ] the Island
that's what they did like amazing
weakness and then [ __ ] get them oh my
God I need help yeah we'll see yeah this
is why I don't know why I just thought
of like all those scary stories I listen
to all the time about like you're
driving on a remote Highway at night and
like you see some car broken down like
somebody laying on the side like oh man
I should stop to help that person don't
stop to help that person then I mean
because that's probably that's a trap is
what that is but um but yeah so it's the
same kind of thing they're like
pretending they need help and then
basically so they'd you know pretty much
pull their guns and they'd be like hey
I'm gonna sink your [ __ ] if you don't uh
give us your stuff and they did this for
like many many years now The Story Goes
that that Black Caesar and his men like
built up this massive massive treasure
and everybody says that they that he
buried the treasure on Elliott key in
Florida now no one's ever found it there
I don't even know if it's really there
or not but that's how the story goes
now what happened to Black Caesar well
we'll find out okay just calm down okay
uh now what happened after that so he
apparently had this big treasure over
the years him and the Sailor were Best
Buds and they had like all these other
men and stuff
um but later on
him and his sailor that had befriended
him on the ship
they had a fight and of course it was
about a woman
Black Caesar ended up killing the
[ __ ] and taking the woman
you know so
hose before bros I guess but I guess was
how that went or bros Well normally it
would be but he did at this time he did
not this time that's why I said who was
before bros that's why that's that's why
maybe he loved her that's what I'm
saying yeah or he just didn't want the
other guy this sounds like a good move I
know somebody should make a Black Caesar
movie yeah I mean I'm surprised somebody
hasn't I mean maybe somebody has I don't
know I don't know of all the movies in
the world but yeah like Black Caesar
seems like a kind of a kind of a cool
dude Black Caesar they're talking about
the black king a black dude he's decked
the emperor he's like Caesar of the
ocean [ __ ] that that that's already
that'd be a good movie
[ __ ] all that black panther [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] MCU fake [ __ ] let's
[ __ ] talk about what really happened
that'd be a good one yeah
he's back in the pirate days
I mean people love pirate movies yeah
and to be cool if it was because the
Pirates of the Caribbean movies are yeah
very very very Loosely based on some
kind of real [ __ ] but I mean it's mostly
just like fantasy yeah it's based on the
ride at Disney more than anything these
wild ass [ __ ] out on the ocean
and [ __ ] no rules but some of the real
stories are better yeah I think yeah but
yeah so uh so he started like amassing
more crew like more Pirates uh over time
and uh eventually like worked up to
going out in the open sea like you know
getting bigger ships so he'd go out in
the open sea and like attack ships out
there like a real big pirate instead of
just being instead of just like faking
like weakness and like taking over your
[ __ ]
um and again they used like a lot of the
uh the keys around the Florida Keys like
to hide in like uh you know Elliott like
old Rhodes key Mangrove islands all that
kind of stuff uh there's another Legend
too that him and his men buried 26 bars
of silver on one of the islands down
there uh again they've never found this
I don't know if it's real or if it's
legendary or not but it's a pretty
well-known like treasure thing that
people look for down there uh this may
or may not be true also but it's fun
he's supposedly also had a harem on his
Island Yeah a hundred women hell yeah
you gotta collect these which he took
for yeah collecting hoes not only silver
bars because like I got all these ladies
as well yeah it probably didn't happen
though probably not probably just his
Legend probably not he was probably
popular with the ladies so they had to
make up a legend oh you had a hundred
yeah I mean 100 seems like a good even
number yeah good even number he had he
had a whole island where he was hiding
yeah it's the I like the island of the
captive women there was a movie called
that yeah it writes itself he probably
had a couple girlfriends everybody wants
to see a movie called Island of the
captive women yeah I mean let's not lie
yeah in reality he was probably just
[ __ ] dude
who's popular big [ __ ] he was
intimidating good at what he did
attracted a lot of [ __ ] dudes who
followed him and women who liked him
that's probably all it was so you're
gonna have to make a story about that he
had a whole hair a hundred women on a
damn Island oh yeah really this is all
[ __ ] that came out of taverns and [ __ ]
pirate bars that's where all this [ __ ]
well that's the thing I kind of feel
like part of the story well it's just
kind of like I kind of feel like Pirates
and cowboys and anything that's like
really like supposed to be like uber
masculine yeah I mean yeah they're gonna
like it's just gonna get more and more
exaggerated like over time yeah it's
like Yeah The Dude maybe had like a
girlfriend and or like a wife and a
girlfriend like an adventurous and stuff
and everybody's gonna blow that up yeah
so you know he's got a hundred yeah yeah
because everyone's gonna like exaggerate
it yeah it's like the Chuck Norris jokes
exactly you know what I mean yeah that's
that's the way reality actually works
yeah well I mean reality doesn't work
like that but
legends about reality because that's
what I'm saying the reality is always
like pretty boring well usually not
always but the reality is usually like a
lot less exciting than the stories
the couple ugly I can I can navigate
through that
I you know I've been to those bars
I've been to those bars and he was
probably
just a good pirate who was charismatic
everybody liked him
and based on that he was successful and
based on that they made a bunch of
stories about him this is his PR
campaign
yeah immediately he's probably just
[ __ ] cool dude yeah we're gonna make
all kinds of money and this isn't it oh
yeah he's he's a regular wheeler a
dealer
that's probably what it is
and he's supposedly like other than
having all these women yeah another
thing that pirates did and I don't know
how much this is legendary and how much
I'm sure this is probably like based in
fact but
Pirates their whole thing like I said
was they just wanted to make some money
so if they couldn't get like some booty
up your ship or whatever if they got
people sometimes they would get people
that could be ransomed for a whole bunch
of money so one of the stories about
Black Caesar is that not only uh did he
have like all these this horrible women
on his Island but he also had like this
big like prison camp where he kept like
people that he would kidnap off ships
that were like valuable right Ransom
kind of uh subjects so he would keep
them there too but I'm not like sure if
that's true or not but I think some
Pirates did do that but to be I don't
know like I'm not a pirate obviously but
it does seem like a lot of trouble
because you'd have to like feed them and
keep them alive and negotiate all that I
just kind of feel like it'd be much
easier to just like with a raid a ship
and take the silver bar what stands out
to me is that he was uh
he had a crew which means that he was
charismatic
he was big okay which that kind of folds
into that because the legend said he was
big
um so he was probably a big charismatic
guy who could lead men
and he was popular all right you could
not
and this goes throughout every all
pirate factoids you could not be a
pirate Captain unless you were popular
if you were a [ __ ] you could never be
a pirate captain
because everything was Democratic it was
between private operators you were voted
into power
yeah if nobody liked you then the crew
would not tolerate right so he was just
some big dude who was good at what he
did and was popular and popular with the
men and popular with the women
that's what I'm getting from
from the Black Caesar Mythos make a
great movie make a great movie it would
or somebody needs to make it yeah I'd
watch it yeah
I mean he was a real person but they
don't really know like how much of the
stuff is like really happened or didn't
well I'm sure he did
normal pirate modus operandi you know
which is yeah you steal [ __ ] yeah you
hold people [ __ ] for ransom uh you do
pirate operations
uh if that didn't happen that he
wouldn't have been popular and he
wouldn't have been he wouldn't have been
remembered
you're probably talking about a guy like
Aaron Edward Teach or Blackbeard a guy
like that that's all yeah and like I
said which I'm not saying that's all
because Edward Teach did some [ __ ]
badass [ __ ] but that's what you're
talking about like an Edward Teach type
guy and Black Caesar didn't know uh
Blackbeard he served on his ship yeah
okay you didn't hear me say that yeah
yeah I'm kind of drunk they said he was
there on the crew like when when
Blackbeard got killed and he probably 17
18. he probably saw how it's done yeah
because [ __ ] Blackbeard was uh
exemplary I mean that's basically the
only thing one of the only things they
know is true about about Black Caesar is
that they're pretty sure that he was on
that crew right so what they're saying
is is that he was from that culture yeah
all right which he was from that scene
so he would have had
uh he would have had the credentials
you know yeah you can't just appear out
of nowhere
all right so
oh you knew Blackbeard okay well that
changes everything
you know
that's that's all so you know oh okay
Blackbeard yeah okay
so yeah I'd love to see that movie
yeah somebody wants to make it but I
mean as of this I mean even to this day
there's an island uh north of Key Largo
that's called Caesar's Rock which is
supposedly named after him and uh
there's a channel there called Caesar's
Creek again supposedly named after him
now
as I said he was a real person they do
know that he uh was on
the Queen Anne's Revenge with Blackbeard
but a lot of the details about his life
they're not really sure if they're true
or not because some of the Legends
around him
um maybe came from some later plays and
things like that like there was a play
from 1798 which is called Blackbeard or
the captive princess which had some of
the details in it which may or may not
be based on reality and there was also a
1922 novel called black Caesar's Clan so
maybe some of the stuff might have come
from that but like I said it could have
been based in reality or maybe not
um what they think happened to Black
Caesar he was actually taken prisoner by
The Virginian Colonial authorities and
he got tried for privacy but he got
acquitted okay interestingly now they
don't really know what happened after he
got released because I think a lot of
the Legends said that oh he got executed
for piracy but he didn't he did he
actually got it yeah which means that
the people sided with him yeah that's
what that means I mean it must have been
because I don't really think they're
Visual Evidence back the [ __ ] was
guilty okay he was a pirate
but the but the people sided with him
and said let him go because everybody
else was doing it
I mean think about it it was a real
profession of its day
everybody else is doing it who could do
it so yeah okay I I get it
he won the popularity contest
yeah I guess that's what happened right
but no one's entirely sure like what
happened to him after he got acquitted
okay they're like since he was an
ex-slave
um it's entirely possible that he was
sent back to his owner you're right
um I doubt that or they said maybe uh he
just went and like worked a regular job
yeah probably what happened and yeah uh
so there's they wouldn't have been able
to send him back he was too [ __ ] you
know what I mean yeah they're just
saying that was a possibility because
that was one thing because he cut his
ass loose and he went out and did what
he wanted and did what he wanted to do
and just like yeah so the record kind of
like lost track of him right
all right so now let's talk about
probably this is really funny because
probably the most famous Florida pirate
uh is the one that has the least amount
of historical veracity
Jose Gaspar
now if you're from the Tampa area and if
you're not from Florida Tampa is on the
west coast the Gulf Coast uh the Gulf of
Mexico
every year they have a festival called
the Gasparilla festival and it is like
Mardi Gras but like I said it's pirate
themed they have the parades it's a big
[ __ ] deal a huge deal
and they've been doing it since the
early 20th century
and it's based around a pirate named
Jose Gaspar which
I don't know I kind of feel like I don't
want to say it's controversial that he's
not a Roper I'm pretty sure that 95 98
99 of Scholars agree that he was
probably not a real person
but every now and then you do get some
stuff thinking he's a real person and
I'll get into like why that is
but his story was just like so
interesting and sort of like emblematic
of like all the piracy that was going on
in this time period that I thought that
I would include it I mean it's kind of
hard to leave out Jose Gaspar even if he
wasn't a real person because he's so
tied in with like the history of Florida
and like for Tampa in particular
so here so Jose Gaspar
um depending on there's a lot of
different like legends about his Origins
uh most of the stories say that he was
probably born in Spain uh probably
somewhere around 1756 and that he was in
the Spanish Navy and then turned to
piracy in about 1783.
uh most of them also say that he died uh
in Southwest Florida during a battle
against the U.S Navy in 1821 but there's
a bunch of different variations of what
happened in between there
so in some versions of this particular
story
Jose uh was a
when he was a kid he was kind of like
um a little bit of a Hellion a little
bit of a troubled
kid
and he decided hey um I'm gonna kidnap a
girl for ransom
so he gets caught and they're like well
you can either go to prison or you can
join the Navy so he's like okay we'll
all join the Navy
and then he supposedly had a pretty
distinctive like uh or distinguished
rather
um Navy career and then uh led a mutiny
against a captain who was kind of a dick
and then took off to Florida in a stolen
ship
uh so that's one version of the story
there's another version of the story
that says that Jose was actually a
nobleman
and he actually got like really high up
in the Spanish Royal Navy and became a
counselor to King Charles III of Spain
um and he was like a real popular guy
like at court but there was some kind of
like romantic Intrigue at some point
um he had like two ladies that were
after him and he kind of like
um spurned one of them for the other one
and the one lady that was spurned got
pissed off and uh you know
brought some charges against him so
there was that uh nothing like rapey or
anything like that but basically said he
stole the crown jewels of Spain
so uh so yeah the authorities apparently
believed her
and said they were going to arrest him
so he's like uh yeah I'm out of here so
he basically stole the ship and took the
[ __ ] off and he's like you guys suck
um I'm gonna become a pirate and [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up for the rest of my life so
that was another version
um and there's still a third version of
this motherfucker's backstory
um in this third version he was a
Spanish admirable ad see I did it again
Admiral I meant to say Admiral uh who
was maybe not the nicest guy
um and he actually did steal the crown
jewels in this version like he wasn't
just Accused by like some bitter [ __ ]
who did who who he like uh spurned he's
like so he did steal the crown jewels
they found out what he did and then he's
like okay well now I'm out so then at
that point like then he stole like the
best ship in the Spanish Fleet took off
with a bunch of dudes that were like
friends of his and in this version he
had wife and kids but he was like [ __ ]
y'all and he just took the ship and the
crown jewels and it's like I'm out and
took the ship and went to the Atlantic
Ocean
so these are three versions of where he
came from
so uh in all the versions though he
eventually ended up settling uh on the
Southwest coast of Florida which uh at
the time obviously still occupied by the
Spanish in 1783.
and he had a ship called the Flora
Blanca and he turned to piracy aboard
this very [ __ ]
he established a base on Gasparilla
Island
and uh was apparently one of the most
feared pirates in the Gulf of Mexico and
uh all in the Caribbean
he supposedly
uh [ __ ] up a lot of ships and amassed
of huge like cash of treasure in uh the
period which coincided with the second
Spanish rule of Florida
and uh just like kind of a lot of
pirates at the time so this isn't like
way out there but if he took your ship
uh the if you were a dude they're like
well you can either join my crew or be
cut up and thrown overboard to the
sharks
uh or if you're a woman then you will be
kidnapped and taken to the nearby aisle
Island and uh there is an island in
Florida which is called Captiva Island
and most of the stories say that this
was where he kept all the women that he
took from the ships hence the name
Captiva uh but yeah the the island is
still called that I don't know if it's
named because of that but that's the
story
uh because they're supposed to be like
concubines or wives for the Pirates or
they're gonna be like ransomed out so
that's where he kept them all and that's
why that island is called Captiva That's
How The Story Goes
now uh one of the most famous stories
about Jose Gaspar from his from his
Legend
this story involves a Spanish or a
Mexican princess depending on who's
telling it
her name is yusepa
and she was actually a PR a passenger on
a ship that he captured and she was a
noble woman now the pirate is like
trying to put the Mac on her right and
she's just like no you uncouth monster
or whatever and then he says I'mma cut
your head off if you don't do what I
want which seems a little
you know
that's really not the way to finesse
your way into that so just saying uh but
she like good for her she was like nope
still not doing it you could be at me if
you want so we did
but to his credit he felt bad about it
afterward reportedly
uh so yeah he he was mad and he cut her
head off but then he felt bad and so he
took her to a nearby Island and he named
the island yusepa in her honor and went
out there and buried her himself I'm so
sorry you wouldn't submit to my rapey
inclinations and so I cut your head off
but now I feel remorse about it so I'm
gonna name an island after you gee
thanks
um there's another Island in Florida
called Sanibel
and The Story Goes that this is
supposedly uh named after
uh the guy who was Jose gaspar's first
mate who is a guy named Rodrigo Lopez
and he had his girlfriend who he had
left back in Spain and her name was
apparently Sanibel so The Story Goes
that the island was named after her
um also something like some versions of
the story too say that this guy Rodrigo
was actually
the guy that was like um Jose Gaspar was
like Hey I have like his diary or his
Vlog or whatever and he's like I need
you to like watch this for me because
it's like super valuable and he was
supposedly the guy that was entrusted
with the with the diary but nobody's
ever found it so I don't really know
like I said nobody's entirely sure if
this guy really existed or not most
people think probably not
uh so Jose Gaspar has been associated
with many other Pirates uh both real
ones and possibly fictitious ones
um
some versions of his story uh have it
that he was partnered up with uh the
pirate Pierre Lafitte who is a real guy
um and that
Lafitte was at the battle that Jose
Gaspar got killed at which we'll get
into in a little bit
um this is a story that makes the rounds
a lot but not super likely
um Pierre Lafitte was a real guy he was
allegedly a pirate but he didn't really
there's no really record of him like
hanging out anywhere around Southwest
Florida where Jose Gaspar supposedly
that was his like stomping grounds
and he actually there is record that he
had died in Mexico before Jose Gaspar
died
um uh on he's also been associated with
Black Caesar or or Henry Caesar which
like I said I'm not no one's entirely
sure if those are the same person or two
different people there's another pirate
named Old King John who may or may not
be a real person
who he's often associated with also
so most versions of this Legend uh come
to the same conclusion that Jose Gaspar
died in 1821.
now 1821 uh was this around the same
time that Spain transferred control of
Florida to the U.S
now Jose
had decided he was going to retire he'd
been a pirate for about 40 years and he
was too old for this [ __ ] I guess
I mean piracy seems like really I mean
yeah wave May way more than being a cop
is like yeah I'm really too old for this
[ __ ] but yeah I'm too old for this [ __ ]
so yeah
so he decides he's going to retire
so him and his crew they go to
Gasparilla Island and uh this supposedly
big treasure cash that he has so we're
gonna split all this [ __ ] up
uh some version of the story say that it
was about 30 million dollars
in those days money
which uh I was looking at Wikipedia and
they said now for a comparison Spain
just sold Florida to the United States
for five million dollars so 30 million
dollars back then was a lot of [ __ ]
cash
so he's apparently like giving out all
of this 30 million dollars to all of his
crew because he's like yeah I'm out I'm
retiring
now
this is Again The Story Goes while
they're giving out the money they're
like okay here's all the money we can
all retire we can just lay on a beach
and drink Coronas the rest of our life
or whatever okay you know it's I know
that's anachronistic I'm just that's
what's funny about it but so The Story
Goes that while they were doing that
one of them sees a British merchant ship
what appears to be a British merchant
ship sailing by and they can't resist it
the pirating impulse is too strong God
damn it we got all this money right here
we could retire forever but look there's
a little more ship it's right there
oh my God we should totally pirate that
[ __ ]
and so they do
they go they get in the Flora Blanca
there's like just one more time
just one more case before I retire like
I said it's just like a cop show
so they decide they're gonna do this
and they go out there and the Pirates
shoot at the ship which like I said they
think is a British they think it's a
cargo ship
um but what happens is that this ship
then slowly just probably like aha kind
of thing they start putting up the
American flag
it's a U.S Navy pirate hunting schooner
the USS Enterprise is what it is and
they were being sneaky and I guess just
like going by this place and let's see
if the Pirates fall for this [ __ ] look
we're gonna pretend look we're a
merchant vessel come pirate us you know
what I mean it's like yeah they did that
USS Enterprise this is a real ship it's
not yeah it's not Star Trek or anything
like that this was a real ship
uh so yeah so they put up the flag and
the Pirates are like [ __ ] me I can't
believe we fell for that [ __ ] uh so
there was like a big battle and the
Flora Blanca pretty much got torn up by
[ __ ] cannonballs because like I said
they're pirate ship they're badasses and
everything but cus Navy
it's a whole like it's a military ship
and they have all the Cannons and all
that kind of stuff so they just like
basically made [ __ ] swiss cheese to
their [ __ ]
uh so yeah so the Flora blacka starts
sinking
at this point Story Goes
Jose
who would not be taken alive God damn it
he wraps an anchor chain around his
waist
and jumps off the ship and he says
reportedly
Gasparilla that's what he called himself
I guess Gasparilla dies by his own hand
not the enemies
that he jumps off the ship and sinks and
drowns himself into the Gulf of Mexico
which is pretty badass if it was true I
don't know if it is but it's it's pretty
funny
uh so yeah
most of the crew uh that were just
minutes before had been like
dividing their spoils on the beach until
that One Last Ship came by and they
couldn't resist it uh most of them got
hanged as so the story goes but if you
escaped or got put in jail
um apparently one of the survivors was
the one that told this story to
everybody else I can't believe Tom
missed the whole like big dramatic death
scene but I'm sitting there getting some
cookies and [ __ ] talking to Pookie
what'd she say
what will happen
well now I have to repeat it so now
everybody has to like and everybody has
to like hear it again
so so yeah so it's a big dramatic ending
okay was this true
nah I don't know
I mean the story's been retold uh in
lots of different versions uh first
appear right around 1900 but there is
actually no evidence that Jose Gaspar
actually existed as a person uh people
many many people have done research in
Spanish archives uh you know so like I
said if he was in the Royal Court that
would have been some record of him
um if he was in the Spanish Navy there
would have been some record of him
um and if he was as badass and he was
like oh wait who's the scariest pirate
in the Gulf of Mexico you'd think
somebody would have heard about him
um not really
they didn't really find any uh
contemporary newspaper reports about
Gaspar Gasparilla anything like that
or of the ship called the Flora Blanca
which was uh what a ship was called and
they actually did a search of the United
States Navy archives and they didn't
find any mention of Gaspar in the ship's
logs or in the official court records of
the piracy trials which were held during
the era of which there were several and
they have records of them now the USS
Enterprise as I said is a real [ __ ] it
was a real ship
and it was
assigned to anti-piracy duties in that
area and in that time period but uh at
the time that Jose Gaspar made his very
dramatic uh I died by my own hand and
not the enemies like throwing himself
off with a chain and everything
um the ship was actually in Cuba when
that happened uh and where Jose Gaspar
supposedly Dives in Charlotte Harbor in
Florida so probably not what happened
now uh there's another thing too there's
a bunch of places in Southwest Florida
that have supposedly been named after
Gaspar
like Gasparilla Island for example but
um actually that had that name before
the story like before that
um the early 1700s like uh maps of the
area by the English and the Spanish have
it already named that uh before the guy
was apparently like active so there's
that
um there are also
you know it's just kind of like there's
really nothing to support him being
alive like there's all these stories
about him having this big home base on
Gasparilla Island which was like a big
compound with a watchtower and all these
houses and stuff but they didn't like a
Pirate Kingdom they called it but they
haven't ever found any um physical
evidence of that
and obviously treasure Hunters have
looked everywhere for his supposed like
big [ __ ] treasure they have found
some coins and stuff but nothing that
would
you know lead to anything like thinking
that he's a real person now where did
this [ __ ] story come from because
like I said Jose Gaspar
they're still books I just read a book
that came out a couple years ago that
still talked about him like he was a
real pirate like in Florida history and
like I said Tampa still has their big
Gasparilla Festival every year which is
kind of like based on him you know yeah
there were pirates in Tampa it's like
they're not just making that up but it
just sounds but this guy was probably
not a real guy okay I mean it might have
been there's a lot in history well yeah
and like I said I'm gonna get into this
is interesting because this kind of
reminded me of remember the story that
you told me about the pterodactyls and
the yeah in the that were stalactites or
whatever in the cave this kind of
reminded me of how how that happened
yeah you know what I mean like this kind
of whole story I gotta drink something
because my the orange media of the
United States was filled with [ __ ]
okay half the damn half the damn
newspapers
lied for a living which I think they
still do
but uh it was called yellow journalism
and they would come up with all kinds of
crazy stories just to titillate the
audiences
well they were just trying to sell
papers like I said because back in the
old days before there was any other kind
of media big cities would have several
competing newspapers so you always had
to have like the best most salacious
juicy stories like to get the edge on
your competition yeah and there were a
lot of really cool stories about
airships
that sound like UFO stories and a lot of
this [ __ ] sounds real credible
but no it didn't happen you know I mean
San Francisco was one of the ones where
it they had this amazing Airship story
about a gigantic Airship with
searchlights and big wings and the whole
city saw it
but just because they wrote that the
whole city saw it doesn't mean that the
whole city saw it you can write the
whole city saw it
this is me and then everybody's like oh
I see it's like oh really the whole city
yeah and you know there's a lot of that
you know yeah like I said in a lot of
ways I think it was worse back then
because you didn't really have like the
energy you didn't have any like fact
Checkers right people just like put
whatever they wanted yeah and then they
would [ __ ] put in fake Witnesses yes
I was there on this and this and that
and I saw the Airship and a ladder was
thrown out of the Airship for [ __ ]
from 40 stories high and a man climbed
down the ladder and asked me for some
tea and I gave him some tea and he
crawled back up and my name is
Abercrombie [ __ ] alien Smith [ __ ]
living on [ __ ] Horsehead Avenue on
426 I saw this [ __ ] and just because
somebody just because this new super
claimed that it didn't mean anything
they [ __ ] claim all kinds of [ __ ] you
know
you can write anything
that's a problem that's the thing well
yeah and I mean ideally yeah
you would have somebody like checking to
see if I'm sure or not but the thing
about well the thing about the Jose guys
well the thing about the Jose Gaspar
story which like I said this is actually
kind of interesting because
of that because of like this the way
that this got
um kind of put into like popular culture
as like a real guy even though he
probably wasn't a real guy he might have
been based on her like Lucy based on a
real guy I don't know but he probably
wasn't a real guy so there's this dude
named John Gomez
now he was a real person
uh he was a guy in the late 1800s and he
lived in this uh on this plate the look
called Panther Key which is a little
island in Southwest Florida now he was
um kind of like a fishing guide and he
was kind of like one of those old like
eccentric kind of dudes that would just
like tell these [ __ ] crazy ass
stories
um and he would yeah I was born in like
1785 I was born in age but you know what
I mean like he would change like this
stories all the time and he wrote like
he like told crazy stories and he was
like kind of known for doing that
so none of his stories were true
probably but he did live all over
Florida he lived in the Everglades in
Key West he lived in Tampa he lived in
that Southwest uh 10 000 islands in the
southwest like [ __ ] like that but he was
really known as like kind of a a guy
who's like a fishing guide and like he
would take you out on his boat and tell
these [ __ ] crazy stories none of them
were true no one really believed them or
anything like that
now interestingly
um you know a couple magazines that were
contemporary like at the end of the
1800s like talked about this dude
because he was kind of well known in the
area or whatever
and
um he claimed at least in some of his
stories because like I said he would
make up new [ __ ] all the time
some of the stories he claimed oh I was
the last guy that was on Jose gaspar's
crew like I saw when he wrapped the
chain around himself and like threw
himself into the ocean and like wouldn't
let himself be taken alive and stuff
like that
um so apparently that was the story that
got taken around but nobody knows if he
told that story because the story first
appeared in 1900
the story about Jose Gaspar actually
first appeared in print
in a pamphlet for a Resort Hotel
um called the Charlotte Harbor Resort
Hotel they were just looking for like
cool stories to get some people to stay
at their hotel
and they told this story about Jose
Gaspar and his whole like
you know very like uh kind of like
dramatic thing that he did at the end
and they said that the source for that
story was Gomez so nobody knows if Gomez
actually told that story and they were
just repeating it or if they just used
his name because they knew he was this
crazy fishing guide that made up [ __ ]
all the time and it sounded like some
[ __ ] that he would say but they didn't
really care they just printed the story
in there because it was a cool pirate
story and they wanted people to come
stay at their hotel so they put it in
their brochure that's the first time
that the Jose Gaspar story appeared in
print in 1900.
so since then
it's basically like so Gomez kind of
went back and forth like was he like a
cabin boy was he on the first maid or
did they just like put his name on it
and nobody knew about that
so the brochure
uh like I said it was this Resort
and the town which is now called Boca
Grande it's like kind of like a it was a
burgeoning tourist area at the time so
like I said this Inn had been built
there
um and it's on Gasparilla Island in
Charlotte Harbor and the guy that wrote
the story was a guy named Pat Lemoyne he
was a publicist and uh he works for the
company that owned the resort
so he's like we really needs like some
cool [ __ ] well it's just kind of like
any like bed and breakfast nowadays it's
like you have to have a good ghost story
or something like that because you want
people to come stay there right so it
was kind of the same thing back then
back in 1900 well like we need a good
pirate story there is a lot of pirate
lore like I said around that area but we
need like a really cool one
so they pretty much made it up and they
said that this guy that was a fishing
guide oh we got it from him he was like
the first mate on the boat or something
like that and it's just like nobody's
gonna check so they did that
um so they just like brought people in
so they have like this illustration
which you can still see if you uh search
Jose Gaspar on YouTube you can still see
like videos about it you can still see
the illustration that was on the cover
of the brochure it's pretty famous
um and yeah they said it was from John
Gomez Who at that point was already dead
so they couldn't like ask him uh you
know if he really told that [ __ ] or not
so all the stuff about
uh you know the the princess and all the
stuff about like how he died and all
that kind of stuff that they said it was
all from him and they did the whole
thing about Captiva Island that's where
he kept all the captives Sanibel was
named after the first mates girlfriend
uh Gasparilla Island was his home and
[ __ ] like that they also said that there
was this burial mound
um which was quote 40 feet high and 400
feet in circumference near gasborough
Island and it had like a whole bunch of
gold and silver in it and there was a
bunch of human skeletons in there but
you know of course people have looked
for that and haven't found it
so it's kind of like this whole romantic
thing and they were just trying to like
sell their hotel basically is what they
were doing now 1949 so almost a half
century later
uh the guy that wrote The Brochure
originally the publicist guy he actually
was still alive and he gave a history
lecture uh at the Chamber of Commerce in
Fort Myers and he told he said the story
about Jose Gaspar the biography of
everything was and I quote a cockeyed
lie without a true fact in it he just
wrote it uh because that's what Taurus
wanted to hear it was just a cool pirate
story and they were trying to get
everybody to come uh see he said yeah I
heard this like fishing guide he told
his [ __ ] crazy stories so I was kind
of like inspired to write him and I just
attributed it to him because I took some
details from him
so basically that's kind of what
happened
so uh what happened after that though
before he came out in 1949 and said yeah
I just made it all up
in 1923 there was this Boston historian
named Francis Bradley
and he was writing a book which would
eventually be
um piracy in the West Indies and its
suppression which is actually like a
scholarly work and very very well
researched but somebody uh sent him a
copy of the brochure from the Gasparilla
Inn
and he Incorporated that into the book
without checking if that story was true
or not
and because the book overall was very
well researched and was you know all
stuff that was documented
everybody thought that oh the brochure
that was in there the story about Jose
Gaspar that was in there that must be
true also because all the other [ __ ] was
true like so this guy's mistake was just
basically getting this brochure from
whoever in the mail and being like Oh
hey that's a good story it's sticking it
in his book and then everybody thought
that it was true
uh but by all accounts it is probably
not
so after that happened because he had
published in his book and that book is
one that other later writers referred to
when they were writing their stuff
because it was you know 99 of it was
very well researched and was factual
um but the fact that the Jose Gaspar
story was in there led many other later
writers to put the Jose Gaspar character
in their books like as though he was a
true pirate
so what ended up happening after that
whether the story was true or not I
think the city of Tampa didn't really
care
they decided that in 1904 they were
going to do what was originally a May
Day Festival but they said hey they knew
the story about Jose Gaspar and they're
like we're gonna do a Jose Gaspar themed
Mayday festival and they called it
gasparable they didn't call it
Gasparilla yet
but the event was so popular
um that what they did was much like in
New Orleans with Mardi Gras they got a
bunch of local leaders together and they
organized a crew you missed it crew of
Gasparilla and they're gonna run the
festivities and this eventually became
known as the Gasparilla Pirate festival
which is still ongoing to this [ __ ]
day
so what they did I mean like I said they
I think they kind of originally thought
that the story was true so they were
just like honoring this pirate or
whatever but then like after they
discovered that probably it wasn't true
they were like yeah we don't give a [ __ ]
if it's true or not because at this
point it's it's just so fictional it's
all parades and everything like that
so I think they admitted in 2004 we
don't care for sure because we know it's
probably that they don't really know
Florida has booty Pirates Florida has
always had booty Pirates they will
always have booty Pirates goodness
but yeah I mean so basically what they
do and they and this goes back to the
first uh Gasparilla in 1904 what they do
is they stage a surprise Pirate Invasion
which actually was like a pretty good
idea like for 1904 that's like a pretty
cool idea for like a [ __ ] event
because like I said Tampa is very it was
a pirate Port so there was a lot of
pirate activity so it's kind of cool
they're like oh we're gonna pretend
there's like a pirate invasions which is
kind of neat so they did that
uh and usually I mean they always had a
May Day celebration prior to that but I
guess it was kind of boring so they
thought well let's do that but we'll
pretend that pirates invaded it and I
was just kind of like yeah that's a good
idea so it people liked it so much that
they decided they were gonna do it like
every year so basically yeah the crew
still does it like I said every year and
actually it's
it's maybe even longer than Mardi Gras
because I feel like it goes on for like
a month at least or maybe two I feel
like it starts at like the end of
January and goes until like March maybe
but yeah so they do like [ __ ]
all kind of [ __ ] Gasparilla season they
help a whole thing and they still do the
invasion like Jose Gaspar like somebody
dressed like Jose Gaspar he comes in
with his crew and his ship and
everything like that uh it happens on
the last Saturday in January they come
and like invade the city
they have like a whole bunch of boats
come across Tampa Bay and then they do
like this big [ __ ] they have this big
pirate ship that they bring in and [ __ ]
like that and then they have a thing
where and they do this every year the
mayor of the city whoever the mayor of
Tampa is at the time will come out and
like give the key to the city to the
Pirates like the Pirates are just kind
of like we're here to take your [ __ ]
he's like here take it Mr pirate yeah
they do that every year and then the
Pirates like will do like woohoo we got
your [ __ ] and they'll like they do like
a big Victory Parade like down down
Bayshore uh so yeah they've been doing
that since 1904 and it's a massive
massive deal I told you I lived in Tampa
for a little while and it's when it's
Gasparilla you out cannot go anywhere
like in that area like around downtown
Tampa Ybor City anywhere like that you
can't go anywhere
um they have like
they say usually like 300 000 people
come to it
uh and it's like a huge boost for the
economy obviously because [ __ ] [ __ ]
tons of people come there I mean it
looks fun but
I'm not I don't really like hanging out
with like big crowds of people uh
especially outside in this you know so
uh I never did go to it but I have seen
like other things of it and it does look
fun like I said it's it's like Mardi
Gras but
not I think not quite as crazy and more
pirate themed you know but it's like
that but they still do it every year I
just think it's funny that they pretend
that they have a Pirate Invasion every
year I told like the mayor of Tampa
every year like pretends to give the key
to the city to the Pirates like they
took it from him and then the Pirates do
a Victory Parade like through Tampa
they just watching all the way from
South Korea what's up Willow wow hey
where are you at did you just got here
because man I just like finished my
notes I actually got through my notes
without
[ __ ] up too much her last name is Lee
she might be [ __ ] South Korean maybe
it was like song or park and I'd believe
it a little bit more but Lee is one of
the possible ones she says your cat is
so cute oh yeah yeah she knows it too
yeah is she in here she's in her little
bowl oh she's in her Bowl yeah yeah she
has a cat tree and there's a little bowl
in it a little fuzzy Bowl yeah yeah it's
like it's a it's like a perfect fit yeah
I was rubbing a bottle of the bone [ __ ]
look at me like huh yeah
yeah it's sort of like a little hammock
she sleeps in that thing like all day
man yeah
Willow's laughing
is he Lee Park or song
quack
I knew I used to know a Korean guy with
the last name of clock yeah yeah they
don't have KW they only have like five
last names yeah most of them are
pursuing and Park
yeah
yeah I thought yeah I thought Park was
the most common yeah that's like Smith
in the united Smith or Jones in the
United States I thought so Park Lee
quack uh [ __ ] let me see what else
oh [ __ ]
that's about that's the main ones
Tammy says this has been a very
interesting show good job in all the
research and telling thank you yeah I
was like super worried about it before I
started you made it through it you
always call me pookie I almost called
you pookie
I was afraid I wouldn't well because
like I said I didn't I didn't like that
I didn't have enough time there's plenty
to do as much research as I wanted
because I wanted to cover some more
stuff but
I mean I feel like that was probably
good yeah that was probably good yeah I
mean I found it really interesting I
wanted to finish that book because give
me like hit me that book that's over
there which one there's a bunch of them
does that no the one that's under it
yeah this book
I bought this in St Augustine
and it's really really good I mean I
haven't got that far into it but it's
not love your channel I love your
channel too
that sounded dirty yeah yeah but yeah
this book is called under the Black Flag
and it's actually
um
it's not so much about piracy in Florida
like I said it's more about
the misconceptions about Pirates like um
the reality of pirates versus the media
conception of pirates so it's kind of
about that but it's about real pirates
too and it's like it's really
interesting I started like reading it
the other day but the one that I read
I read like one that was
um kind of based on Florida Pirates
specifically and that was like pretty
interesting although like I said I do
kind of look at scance because he did
talk about Jose Gaspar like he was a
real dude you didn't want to come down
now oh she's here she's here she's here
there's food hey little one yeah oh my
goodness so you left the boat you left
the boat I had to come out of the bowl
somebody was talking about me we were
talking she sensed it she sensed it look
at her little feet yeah she's like [ __ ]
this she's like [ __ ] off
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] I'm out of here she's
looking behind us she's yeah I gotta
investigate
that it's all the same poke it's the
same nothing's changed he's looking
behind the poster
the pitcher
Hugo's talking about
um
uh hey Tom speaking of pirates we made a
couple of replicas a 50 cal Queen Anne
1690 70 20 and a 50 58 Cal Harper's
fairy pistol first American-made gun
1807. okay that's cool
okay
that's all I'm gonna say about it okay
remember what he's talking about gee
I don't know I don't know what you're
talking about
poor Sam yeah no no are you really that
drunk yeah no they've made a lot of
American Guns there were American Guns
before there was United States of
America
so it's hard to tell what's American
yeah
you guys are the same didn't matter
Hugo said great show guys too bad I
missed like half hour
um you didn't
as much as you might think because we
started late because we were having all
kind of like connection problems yeah
you know
all right Danny Rowling said Florida
Pirates probably made some captors walk
the plank and Gator infested water all
the time if they actually did walk
through the plank just saying yeah I
mean yeah I kind of feel like
wasn't that that was a Peter Pan thing
too wasn't it didn't they have a
crocodile in it
with a clock tummy or something like
that yeah
Mr Smee yeah
and even like the Peter Pan ride at
Disney I don't even know if they still
have that that used to scare me that
[ __ ] crocodile yeah crocodiles are
scared I'm not worried about it of
course you're not you're not worried
about anything no you're not worth it I
don't care
I don't care I don't care I don't care I
don't care
why doesn't Johnny care
if you're an MST fan you'll know what
I'm talking about
yeah ready I got 9 20. let's go ahead
and shut it down man we've been going
for three hours and 14. are you hungry
yeah I'll make somebody come on okay
cool all right all right well thank you
everybody for dropping by this evening
this was a fun show to do even though I
was worried about it but it came out
okay
um but yeah so be sure to drop by on
Friday evening we'll be doing the side
track show we're just going to talk
about whatever [ __ ] flits into our
minds okay which you know that could be
dangerous but uh yeah so uh yeah have a
good rest of your evening have a good
day tomorrow and we will see you guys
again on Friday evening like share
subscribe do all that regular stuff and
we will see you again on Friday bye